Experience.
Nicholas, me, boy, Joey, boy.
We've known each other for many decades
and now we're both wear reading glasses.
Look at this ladies and gentlemen,
fucking irritate fucking old men.
We can't see up close. So sad.
Did you notice when you came in?
I ripped mine off like you were abroad.
It's like one of those things.
If someone calls,
you know and you're sleeping,
you always lie about it and it's like,
what do you need those nod to him?
Don't need those. I only use those
for numbers. I'm in the restaurant.
I have to wait,
just hold on the menu.
She's 11 and 11 feet from my
table so I can read. Yeah,
in low light conditions and less.
I have my camera on my,
my phone with the flashlight, you know, so
I can use, I could read it if I have my,
but otherwise I don't know
what the fuck at the bill is.
You need to step up the bifocals so you
can wear them all day long and I'll be
going, I don't need them past like
my arm's length. It's, that's right.
My friend Steve Graham explained it to me.
He's an ophthalmologist.
I guess when you get older, your, your,
your eyes just lose their ability to
focus up close and then this shit doesn't
help.
Computers don't know.
It's the worst pawn on your cell
phone at three in the morning.
That's not what I'm talking
about. I'm talking about
work. I don't know a year. No,
no. You're talking Nick
Depaulo. How dare you.
Apparently you're doing a lot more than
I am. Joe. Uh, you went back to New York,
Huh? Yeah. How long ago did you go
back? I was out here. Oh, Christ.
I was out here from 95 to 99.
And you were like enough for think
Chris rock called. Yeah, I had it not,
I swear to God,
this is a true story.
I was in my own shower at my house arguing
with an imaginary fucking age and I
didn't have,
I'm not fine.
I swear to God my wife heard
me in this house, be right,
did and I'm like,
I'm fucking losing my mind out here.
And then like a bolt from God.
Chris rock called.
He started his HBO show and said,
I want you to be one of the writers,
and I was like,
you gotta be shitting me.
I was on the fucking next plane out
looking, looking down at all the bridges.
I burned in La.
You could see the fires from
nick played my brother on news
radio. There was a, there was a,
I want to say it was a confusion,
but it would be a lie.
It was an agent tried to fuck him.
A casting agent tried to fuck them over.
We had already booked him for the part
and all the sudden this casting agent
goes, oh, I've already booked that.
I've got this guy coming in and I go,
what are you talking about?
I go, it's supposed to be
Nick Depaulo. He's my friend.
He's going to be my brother. My other
friend Brian counts, my other brother.
It's already booked. She goes,
well, I don't know what to do.
You know I've already got this guy books,
so you're going to have to tell nick.
Oh No, no, no.
I get near this to tell this fucking
other guy because she had already called
you and told you you didn't. That's
right. She came out and said, uh,
you guys can go whatever.
She tried to weasel casting female
casting agents in many circumstances are a
lot like male casting agents.
You know the casting couch,
the notorious casting couch. Yes. How
bad you want it. The part and you know,
well this,
this gal had a male friends
and these male friends, uh,
apparently, uh, she, she enjoyed
their company and so she would, uh,
get them gigs even if those
gigs weren't really available.
And that was what was going on. And she
was just going to weasel this guy. Yeah.
Yeah. And I was walking to my car and you
came running out and go, hey, hey, hey.
I go, what? And then I felt bad. I'm
like, now did I just fuck somebody over?
Cause I know Joe. No you didn't
fuck anybody. You were already,
that was a stellar after
you were outstanding, but
you were approved and done.
It was over. But she just tried to
weasel it in. It was fucking gross. Oh,
oh, it was that Horace name. Oh, no need.
No need to name names and who it might
not. She might have been on medication.
Who knows what the fuck.
That was a fun episode that we beat
the shit out of each other through each
other through windows three
Stojich and we did a scene,
we actually did a scene that it said was,
it came across to violent Joe and
Brian at it. Remember what the coffee,
we had a glass coffee pot or I hit you
over the head and smashed me over the
head and then we kick and jellies
down and they said it looked too much.
They actually said it looked too much
like Goodfellas. Dinero was kicking a guy.
Remember he had the, so uh, it was it
last week. I got to break this thing off.
He had like five times. Yeah. I got to
fly through a glass window. You know,
they have that candy glass. So I went
flying through a window. It was fun, man.
That was a fun episode. And you know
who Epstein from from welcome back.
Kotter Epstein from welcome back.
Kotter was our oldest brother who was a
priest that we were all terrified of his,
I think he's dead too, isn't he? Did he
pass away? No. Kiddin what was his name?
He's got a Dutch team from welcome back.
Guys are going to be born then. Yeah.
Um, I didn't know he died. Did he really
die either? Either that or I'm stunning,
ugly grow right now, but I, I,
I realize this might have jack died
now you will hope in horse shit.
Don't confuse your hopes that you
went, oh wait a minute. You know what?
You're right. Is it, is it
Horshack he and the Black Guy,
I think they're all bad actually Gabe,
cause you know who else died?
The wife died. Oh, he died in
2000 wife died. You were right.
He died in 2012 he did.
You know,
maybe he's from that episode was
a lot of violence going. Wow.
He looked like shit before he died. What
the fuck, man, when we knew that's him,
that's him. That's Robert Hedges. When we
knew him, he actually looked pretty good.
It looks like a candy Crowley from CNN.
Some of those guys that get a really
good gig like a welcome back Connor.
And then after that it dies.
Those fucking guys never recover.
It's like they're living the
fucking life there. Yeah.
Nice bagels from craft service. Everybody.
Good Morning Mr Hedges. How are you sir?
Get your coffee. Would you
like something? And then uh,
this fucking cruel machine just
spits them out. It's a hard fun.
And then you want home. I, yeah.
When did he turn into a
Hawaiian woman before he died?
What the fuck? Who Does he look early
from? Loss. You know what happened?
He probably went all spiritual. Look at
all the necklaces and stuff he's wearing.
You probably went all spiritual.
Probably it was all going downhill
or maybe he had cancer or something.
Maybe now I feel bad. He
was a dude, man. He was,
and he knew that that was like a thrill
to meet the guy died of a heart. Yeah,
it was. We were kids when that show was,
you died of a heart attack, 60 years old.
And I think I know the woman,
the wife,
the played the wife and that
showed just died of cancer.
Well I'm the Cape Chaplain's wife
on the show. She just died recently.
Meanwhile, John Travolta looking great,
sucking cock all over the planet.
Apparently it's how you get rhythmic.
Well he definitely doesn't
look ripped anymore. No,
you're right. He's Kinda Kinda,
yeah. Who looks the best from that? Well
him, he looks the best from that show.
I want the black guy that
played Washington cause he's
still around. Freddy. Boom,
boom. Washington. Yes. Hills.
We are dating ourselves,
but it's relevant because they're
dead and we're getting close to it.
Nobody knows who they are anymore.
That's what's fucked up. No, I know.
Let's talk about, let's find the guy,
if they just did a loss, reference it.
I've never seen the show
you never saw last. No.
This is the first network gave
a really good, I rewatched it.
Joe's way better if you know what happened
because now you're only focusing on
what you're really
supposed to be focusing on.
Not The bullshit that
makes you hate this show.
But here's that picture of Freddy. Boom,
boom, Freddy, boom. Is he still alive?
Lawrence Hilton. Jacobs is his name.
Yeah, it looks good. Yeah. He's,
he's the best looking guy at all
of them now. And Horshack checkout.
I think you're right. He seemed
shocked is done. I think you're right.
I think horse sharks debt.
Let's say that shows kind of Jenks
now the you'd think of not really.
It's just life. Well, they're
not that. Hello. It's just
what's true, which is like,
yeah, he died in 2012, two same
year that, uh, Epstein died.
And Gabe cod, who's a like degenerate
gambler. Is he a degenerate? Well,
that's what I heard. I know he's a poker
player and maybe I'm stretching the,
those two are kind of synonymous. Club
owner told me that. Did you ever do that?
Kj Rentals in Orland Park, Illinois, a
guy named Kenny round? No, never does.
He used to have Gabe
cod are in there and uh,
gave copies to hate going to bring this
stuff to the airport and our luggage and
had hate to check it. He used to mail
it, spend like three, $300 a mailing.
It's closed really.
And he went and he,
this guy took him out
gambling and some casino. Um,
he was there the weekend before I was
any, any, uh, he won. Like he won,
like he said, 750,000 betting
on football. And I said,
you mean 75 that he goes, no, 750,000.
This guy, Kenny wouldn't lie either.
Uh, but he, this guy, he was
like, he's like a heavy intuit.
When you start getting
to those big numbers,
that's fucking dangerous because
it can all go away like that. Well,
I'm going to pool,
I put $5 on the beginning of the year
and I'm trying to beat my niece, Jenna.
That's helping. That's helping.
I mean, is it gambling is fun,
don't get me wrong.
But the thing about gambling is that like,
you got to keep pushing the stakes to
keep up in that thrill, to try juicing.
Your veins are already lang used to,
he used to go hard and oh my God,
he told me some of the num and in a
norm norm is the worst, right norm.
Norm Macdonald's supposed to be like
the worst of all time. Oh my God.
It's like again so bad.
I couldn't get on his podcast this week.
What kind of numbers?
Well I already told me story about norm
and he says it's absolutely true that he
won. He won like 60 grand one
night and he walked out. Uh,
where would they gambling? What the hell
was it? It wasn't Vegas cause it was,
there was an ocean nearby.
Any throw all the money in the ocean
cause he knew he was going to Piss it away
anyways. Why? That's yeah, that's
what I already told me. I wouldn't,
I wouldn't doubt that. I
wouldn't need that. You know,
norm telling my legit crazy.
We were,
we were having a great time on a plane
once and just randomly sat next to each
other. It's just total dumb
luck. Had a great time.
Lino three hour flight
laughing and cracking up and
talking to all kinds of shit.
He's like, wow. Yeah. I quit smoking
a long time ago. I'm just so happy.
I quit smoking and then as he lands,
he goes, spa, I want a cigarette.
He walked right into the fucking, one
of those duty free shops at the airport,
bought cigarettes and it just
couldn't have them in his hand.
As he was walking out the
door and lighting them,
couldn't wait to get out
the door to light him. I go,
what happened to Quintin
cigarettes? He goes, I quit Quintin.
I just wanted a cigarette.
It was so great.
I mean, just an hour ago talking about
how much he's happy. He quit cigarettes.
He quit a long time ago and then this
switch goes off and he just impulsively
decides time to have a cigarette.
I go to his hotel and he's in New York.
A few years ago,
I had a bunch of sets at night.
It's like two in the morning and he
tells me to come up to his hotel.
He's drinking black coffee by the pot.
He drank.
Like I took pots in front of me and I can
hear her stomach gargling cause he had,
he had some stomach problems he says,
and I can hear him make any songs
and he's just too full pots and I go,
what?
He didn't do stay up for three day night.
I'm immune to it and it
doesn't even bother me, Eh.
Some guys can just drink coffee like Tate
Tate and drink coffee and go to sleep.
My friend who owns caveman coffee,
people become immune to this year.
He drinks coffee and then you can pass
out. I don't, I'm like a little puss.
I have a half a cup but I'm all over
the place like a fucking meth addict.
It's one of those things
if you do it a lot,
if you drink a lot of coffee it
sort of becomes normal. But if you,
if you take a few months off a coffee
and then you realize what a drug caffeine
really is. I actually have a bit
on my album. It was a good segue.
I knew one nick dip. Yeah, Nick Dip
Com. You can get it. By the way.
What's the name of the [inaudible]?
Another senseless killing.
But uh,
I have a caffeine bid on
there because I'm like hyper.
I get fucking like, I'm also
allergic to it. You're what?
I'm almost like allergic to it. If I have
most alert, I have a couple of cups. No,
I, I can't even like focus. Really? Yeah.
So it's an unusual feeling that you get.
Yeah. I don't, uh, has this
always been the case? No. No.
This is a recent, yeah, it's
like the eyes. Yeah. Oh yeah.
It's deliver. No, it is Joe.
The immune system can't even fight
out of caffeine. Now we're going,
we're going like fucking Horshack.
We can we play that enough caffeine
clap. Yeah. Yeah. Here, let's play it.
Caffeine.
Here we go.
That's a great setup. Negative guy. Have
a caffeine problem. Just found that out.
I like, I mean, I'm
almost allergic caffeine.
I was laying in bed the
other night thinking,
how come I've been in like 12 fist
fights before noon time over the last 20
years.
I'm like hyper alert.
You guys have a couple cups of coffee,
you get a little jittery.
It's like bath salts for me.
I'll show you fucking face off
and leave you in the street.
I go to Dunkin donuts. An hour later
I'm naked in my driveway. Restaurant.
Three cops. Tasering my balls.
What's he on? Angel Dust. No,
I had a Cappuccino with three sugars.
Get back in your car.
I'll fucking true your nose,
but I get really nasty as
opposed to by natural state.
I've had some of the worst fight to
my wife and I was jacked up on coffee.
Last January. True Story. It's a Sunday
morning. My wife comes down the stairs.
She goes, uh, my nieces and
nephews are coming over.
We're going to a petting zoo and
you're coming with us and I'm like,
I've been following the Patriots for 16
weeks. Today's the first playoff game.
But yeah. What better time to
look? Got a gold Lang is on shit.
Was it an accident?
Cut to me were like half hour later
I'm in a bar and looking at animals.
I have like a pot of coffee and my gut.
I'm crawling out of my skin.
This guy next to me goes to me the most
condescending. Tony goes, that's a Yak.
I go,
yeah,
I know what to fucking act as a sign but
on the cage and it had a read asshole
and then I realized he was talking to his
four year old son on the other side of
it.
Is that not a classic caffeine?
How do you get out of that one?
I just stayed in the asshole role,
went till the next cage and it was a goat
in there. I just looked at him. I went,
let me guess duck. What is that?
A pigeon come on Doctor Sushi.
No fucking everything.
What does that right.
Even as a little kid was
looking up at me like,
who pissed in your cheerios mister? And
I'm like, fuck you, you little pussy.
I for a Pumpkin at him. My wife pushed
me out of the bag. What'd you record
this? Keep? There's what? Go ahead.
There's one more. One more caffeine story.
This was about a month and a half later,
White Plains airport sit next to this
obese guy for like two hours ignoring his
smell. He hadn't said a word to each
other. All of a sudden he gets up,
he looks at me and this tone of voice,
he goes, I'm going to the shitter.
Watch my bag.
That's totally am I caught on. I get
bags are not gonna explode in 30 seconds.
He goes, well, look like a terrorist.
I go, that depends. He goes,
depends on where to go.
If I was a cheeseburger,
I was a fresh garden salad.
I feel very comfortable watching your
bags in the next 20 minutes or a pack of
sweet low, but you're like butter.
Let's be honest, and that's it.
I did that at acme. Oh yeah, that's
a great club. My favorite club,
it's a great club.
It's a low ceiling and it's,
I say, I think it was
like 270 people. Yeah,
there's like five of those type of
clubs like helium, comedy works,
you know all those like low
ceiling, tight, tight clubs.
Joe is his Denver like that. I haven't
been in the comedy works in you. God.
It's the best I know. I get kicked out of
the rap to, to some Bachelorette party,
ruin my fucking shell.
The second time I was there and I called
him fat conch and the girl who ran the
place was of that gun. So she
didn't like that. Oh, how dare you.
I hope you still not running it.
She, of course she owns it now. Well,
I don't think it was
Wendy. Really? How long?
Just had to be 18 years ago.
Oh, it was probably one day
a rally. She's on morning.
I apologize. She couldn't have been
on it and get then. All right. Yeah.
She owned it from the start.
Oh. Cause she wasn't there.
Now the owners are never even
on their charge back then.
And then she got like Tommy things
done and while she stapled Yam,
she went with the, you know, they
do those things well, it's no need.
It's still no reason to let a
bad truck party ruin my shot.
I hear yelling with you. That's
what you did yours, right?
Yeah, yeah. Killer. Right.
I love that place. Yeah. It did my uh,
rocky mountain high or the last one,
my comedy central special. I decided
I'm doing them all from now on in clubs.
Yeah. I I did, uh, the last one I did,
Ron nerve was in at
comics w which is a club,
but it was like we squeezed like 500
people in there and um, you know,
people do these big theaters and they
start to all sound alike or like kind of
cookie cutter.
You don't capture that,
that energy that I think you could
get away with a theater. I mean, uh,
I did a talk in monkey's in space.
My next set,
my second favorite one that
was in a theater in Columbus.
Nice little theater though. I like a
900 seats. Oh, that's perfect. Yeah.
But I think the, once you go
to like 2000, 3000, it's you,
you lose a bit of the interaction with
the crowd. Yeah. There you are. An acme.
That's a fucking club. That's a great
club. Those classic low ceiling clubs.
That's,
that's why your comedy is hypnotic.
Like everyone gets roped
into your energy mindset.
Energy stays right in your face.
You do ride it and they write it.
And it's also like, I feel
like, um, when you're, you, you,
you don't miss any of the tags. You
don't miss any of the, I didn't,
have you ever sat in the
crowd at a theater before? Uh,
just to add a Letterman tape and
when I first moved to New York, yeah.
But that's different, right?
Because that's like not a
standard. No, I went to a,
I was in New Jersey and Joey
and I, Joey Diaz and I, we're,
we're doing Friday night and a Lewis
Black was there on Thursday night.
So we had gotten there early. We flew in,
we said, well, let's go say hi to Louis.
We'll sit in the audience.
So we went and sat in the audience and
he would get a big laugh and then he
would have a tag line. Nobody couldn't
hear the tagline. And I was like, oh,
you can't hear out here
because everyone's laughing.
There was too many people like around
you that were laughing and the sound just
didn't penetrate to that.
How big that was that then 22 lines,
2,400 something like that.
I'll never get any of that
unfortunately know it's a little larger.
That's my goal to make a bad specialty
in front of 2100 people. Actually,
I would love to be able
to fill 2100 seats.
I don't give a shit how
the special came out,
but when you do get a big laugh
and like 3000 people to wait,
what's the biggest crowd
you've ever performed for? Um,
radio city, I think, but
the dentist Larry was a,
I want to say 7,060 500 or so.
Oh.
Then we did some of the staples center.
That's where it was.
Staples San was even bigger.
It was like 7,000 I think out here in
la I did a Kevin and being have this a
April fool's day thing,
the April fools weekend,
and it's a 7,000 that was
the biggest I've ever done.
It's weird because it's had some theater
at universal and they're all in front
of you.
It's like a wall of people.
It's like a real steep incline so that
like the top row is like right in front
of you. Like everyone's right in front
of, it's a very strange theater, but it's,
that makes it intimate. Yeah, it's great
for 7,000 people. It's as good as it gets.
The, I did want to Seneca
Casino, uh, this past October,
I think it was like 550 seats,
but same thing, theater seating.
And if I have a shot, something
else, I'd love to do it there.
Those casinos can be fucking weird.
Like you can suck or they can be great.
That was a great one. But they,
they hit a mess. You're right.
Those Indian ones in
Connecticut. Oh, fucking Christ.
You don't know what you're getting.
Especially the people like Connecticut.
Connecticut is a fucking strange.
You got people around the edges
that are near Boston or the,
that are not in New York that are cool,
but they're like Kinda like, yeah,
I didn't want to live in the
city. I like, I want a yard.
So they'd go to Connecticut and then
you've got those fucking deep Weirdos that
live in those point where you
have to drive five miles an hour,
cause deer jumping across the road
every five seconds. Yeah, yeah.
You got an urban met, you've got hard
for it, and then you get a, yeah,
the woods and then you get the snowdy
people in Greenwich and Hartford.
Surprisingly shitty. I know you
think of Hartford, Connecticut.
It sounds regal, like
Hartford, Connecticut probably
was at one time. Yeah,
it's Waterbury. Connecticut. Yeah.
We used to be like a textile.
It was unbelievable. Back in the
fifties it was a beautiful city.
Now you know,
you know,
I used to do gigs in Waterbury and get
a bowl of driving through them. Yeah.
It's a rough area.
There's a lot of rough spots there.
My wife's from outside of Waterbury.
Yeah. I think the best place to stop.
She's a witch doc that I
mentioned that. No, no.
She's from a little town from outside
of Waterbury, but I mean it's,
don't get me wrong. Some nice
people there, but they're all dying.
Get Out. Cause I don't like seeing,
I don't like to Mexico. See,
I don't want eat VA. I don't
like, I guess if you're a Gambler,
I can see love and stay in
there for a week, but, but
I hate when I have to do it.
Casino. I just don't, it it, it, to
me, it draws the fucking dregs of the,
he said he's people like during the late
seventies you're wearing dirty running
shoes at a members only jacket
on a Friday night, you know,
and you think you're lucky.
The fuck makes you think you're lucky.
You're wearing dirty running shoes and
a maps only jacket and you just put two
grand into the wheel of fortune machine.
You fucking loser.
And then they get pissed and
they come to the show, right.
Sit with that puts on their face.
Well,
especially those casinos feel like you
are only here because you're a gambling
junkie. You're not taking a weekend
in Vegas. I'm going to go to Vegas.
We're going to see some shows now.
We're going to go to the stratosphere.
We're going to ride the rides. Ooh,
no, none of that. Fucking Connecticut.
And then you play in the craps table,
the guy next,
she is like a 20 year old kid wearing a
Nick's shirt. He's a basketball shirt,
like you know,
fucking and work boats.
What do you think you to dress up like
back in the rat pack days? Not Dress up,
but what the fuck? You don't have
to look like crap. The collar.
A little collar on your shirt. I'm not
saying that, but a little alligator.
I have no shirts. I hate
them. Do you remember when
we were kids? Kids would, uh,
they would so fake
alligators on like generic.
Well the kids in south he with
like the poor kids, right? Yeah.
And you get mad at you if
you want to check their tag,
it doesn't have it notorious. B
I g has a song about that. Right.
It doesn't check in your tag. Yeah.
Like someone's trying to, and like,
you punched him in the face like,
yeah. There's like a song where he's,
he punches somebody in the face where
they try to check his tag because a reason
for violence. Look, he's
questioning your brand.
You've got to do what you gotta do.
If you're in certain neighborhoods,
you know you've got to keep your Rep.
The fake ones always look
just like the alligator,
but it's just like a tadpole or a lizard
or something. Yeah, it's a little off.
Yeah.
Can never,
you have to have nothing on your shirt
or is it a weird how fucking brands
become like something
that everyone has to have?
It's so fucking strange how sheepish
people are with that kind of stuff.
Sheep like, Eh, I need to wear
what everybody else is wearing.
Otherwise you're not in,
you know, like brand.
I know people that they want
to have everything brand name,
you know,
like everything has to be brand name.
And if it's not brand name like well
it's just as good. It doesn't matter.
You know,
my wife you talking about
bye fucking generic. I do a bit
about, we have mice in our basement,
so I put traps down. She can't I, I caught
a put an imported Parmigiano Reggiano,
cheese and one of the fucking
tracks at 18 bucks a pound.
Really about Kraft singles. What the
fuck she was putting imported cheese.
She just wanted, you know, click cheese.
Yeah. That's all we had in the fridge.
And I'm like, oh, what are you fucking,
you know when he Lima Biscardi don
and I fucking an espresso maker.
It's one of my older bits.
But so what? It's true.
Somebody has a good joke about piscotty.
No, no. Uh, no. Pastry is good.
If you have to dunk it in
coffee first ESOP, nobody eats.
But Scotty raw
cuts the underside of your mouth.
Oh, Sarah wine shake has one.
She has a Scottie bit. Yeah.
It's not her, it's a guy. I know.
It's a guy who has the bit,
but yeah, I mean it's one of
those things. It was like,
well, I'm like, when
you go to a fucking, uh,
like I'm one of those
coffee beans and they have,
what are those hard like triangle looking?
It's not a,
it's a blueberry Scott Stone.
Fuck's going on.
I want a muffin. And all you have is
scones. Bullshit. Fuck scones. Lemon bars.
Not Bad.
I disagree with you there.
I don't mind the lemon bars.
I just,
I just feel like pastry
should be mostly soft.
I don't mind a little crusty outside
and he looked like you did coke right?
Updated a little ticket,
dessert powder all over your face.
I've never done coke but I'm always
paranoid that people think I'm doing coke.
Coke. You found some old old coat that
I've, I haven't warned him like 10 years.
I'm just like going through it and I'm
like what the, I just put a little baggy.
Yeah, I had like four lines in it,
but I'm just thinking like who,
what night did I go?
You know what? I'm done.
I'm just going to save this for
later. What the fuck man, that's not,
how do you know it's coke? It
might be rice. It might be like,
I know how to kill this dummy. But he
hated something you posted on Youtube.
I just put some fucking something at
a coke bag and leave it as jacket.
Hilson Nord it,
it's true cause I don't remember ever
even buying coke or having somebody wanted
to kill you.
All do would have to do is buy you drinks
the comedy store and then hand you a
bag anthrax and you be like,
fuck cancer
burns. What? Joe? Now this is,
you've changed since I've known you.
I mean you'll like this cosmic
fucking you're doing, what's the Dsm?
Amity DMT. Yeah. That's way
different than coke. No, I know.
No, I know. That's why I'm saying
I would risk a heart attack.
I'd rather do this shit. That shit.
I would never, I'm, I'm scared.
Shit of that stuff. Why scared
some people don't come back, dad.
That's not true. That's, it's not
like LSD. It's the thing about DMT.
Well first of all, your brain
makes it, it's common in the body.
Well then I have not a bit, I've
never had it. Do you have dreams? Oh,
do I ever, there you go. Can I
take a drink? Kava? I have vine.
Samo Kava. Yeah, yeah, yeah. That gives me
dream. Yeah, that'll do it, right? Yeah,
for sure. Yeah. There's a lot of
Melatonin gives some people freaky dreams,
sometimes just taking
vitamins before you go to bed.
Sometimes people get weird dreams.
How bout if you kill your wife or
before you go to bed, got over,
make you fucking horrible drink. Just
probably won't sleep. Acetylcholine
is a big one.
Take acetylcholine before you go to sleep.
You will have the fucking wild. Is that,
and where do you get this shit? Yo,
it's crazy. Fuck. Well it's, it's
a, it's actually just a plant.
It's an extract from plants. It's one
of the main ingredients of Alpha brain.
But who turned, who turned
you on to this shit? Ah,
the Internet just started doing
the church. Nicotine Patch.
Just put a nicotine patch before he
go to bed and it keeps your nicotine.
That's a good place for it.
Yeah. Does it really? Yeah.
It keeps your nicotine receptors alive.
Well,
there's a bunch of different nutrients
that are shown to have a positive effect
on your memory and the
way your brain functions.
So I started researching them about 10
years ago. I started getting into him,
taking different ones,
a bunch of different vitamins.
And it wasn't a bunch of friends that
said, you gotta do this shit. What?
DMT is different. I mean, this is,
we're talking about like acetylcholine
and nutrients and perhaps on the DMT DMT
or die shit that I've found out about.
Well,
I heard about it first through this
guy named Terrence Mckenna, who was,
I've heard about Terence Mckenna
through an old bill Hicks joke.
Bill Hicks did it show talking about yeah,
about tenants with 10 yeah, yeah, yeah.
With Terence Mckenna would call a heroic
dose. So I was like, who is this test?
That kind of guy. And so I bought a
Terence Mckenna book and I was like,
Holy Shit.
Is this guy going deep?
I think I bought a food of
the gods is crazy fuck book.
This guy who was just,
I mean,
at the time when I'd never heard anything
about like much about psychedelics,
I mean, when I knew people
that did mushrooms just like,
let's get fucked up. Hey,
I've got some mushrooms.
Woo,
we're gonna go see some crazy shit that's
not really there. Did you do that shit?
Oh No, I didn't do much. I
didn't party at all. Like in,
I might have smoked pot five times
before I was 30 maybe at the most,
six or seven before I was 30 when I mean
it was all, it was all when I was drunk.
You know, it's like a party drunk.
Someone's got a joint. Yeah, fuck it.
I'll smoke some of that. And then I was
like, oh, I don't want to do that again.
Yeah. You know, it freaked me out. I can't
feel my feet, you know, that kind of shit.
That's what surprises me.
Then you do this shit.
Well then I started getting in a
pot. I enjoy it now. I love pot.
It's one of my favorite tax.
Yeah.
Once I hit about 30 31 I started hanging
out with my friend Eddie Bravo and
Eddie Bravo,
who is a musician,
was telling me that it makes them more
creative that he likes. Like I was like,
makes me dopey. And he's like,
you sure? Like if you ever live,
you ever smoked it by itself or
smoking it when you're drinking?
So we smoked some and then I was like,
this is the best shit ever.
And we went and got ice
cream Sundaes and I was like,
I can't fucking believe ice cream Sundaes.
Taste is good.
And then you wrote a bit on, no, it's
just true ice cream Sundae. I should,
I probably should have. I missed
the boat. But Sam, really? Oh Dude.
Sex feels so much better when you're high
and you kind of weed,
it makes you hyper sensitive.
That's why people get paranoid.
The reason why you get paranoid is
because most of us put blinders on because
you have to to get through
life. I mean there's, you know,
we're on a fucking planet.
We're flying through space or riding
around in metal boxes, you know,
60 miles an hour on the highway.
Anybody at any moment in time could just
fucking turn into the oncoming traffic.
And you have to put blinders on to get
through life. And we ignore things.
And then when you smoked pot, he goes,
hey, you ever think about this? You know,
like, yeah, but I'm trying
not to. And then people,
I don't like pot because
it makes me paranoid.
I think it just makes you hyper sensitive.
Last time I smoked, it was in, when
I first moved to New York City,
I was in an acting class.
It's cute girl and go back to her
apartment like five of us from the class,
smoke this shit. Then I had to
go on the way home. I'm going to,
I go to the bank chemical bank,
I'm in line,
I'm like fourth in line and they had a
digital thing where your number comes up.
So finally I get to the front,
my number comes up and I fucking lady
just stared at me and I ran out the door.
That's a true story. Just
freaked out. She look like,
I mean school teacher and
I just fucking bolted.
That's the last time that was like
in the early nineties that's fun.
Do you want to smoke some? You know, I
bet you would help me with my insomnia,
wouldn't it? Sometimes, but
then again, what if it's really,
I hear it's like the weed
today is obviously way
stronger than what was going on
until like 50 times one hit now
a days and just see if it works.
Got Some rain here and move to pause.
One hit when going to help when his place.
Look at this skulls and shit. That's
all I need. Milkweed and look at this.
This fucking go ted,
you got over here.
That's a boost that I shot a couple
months ago. Getting the one oh one
no. Yeah, it was an invader from Canada.
It didn't have his green card.
I fucking took it out from America.
No,
shut that one in Canada.
If you lived around here and
give you some Moose takes.
I've got 400 pounds of it in my
few railing joke. Testosterone man.
It's fucking hilarious. Cousin. I got a
cousin of a hunt with a bow and arrow.
He's got all kinds of, yeah,
I've done some of that.
I shot a bear with a bow and arrow.
You do that shit high and Nah, no,
no, no, no. I'm fine. Yeah, it's not
bad. Caveman coffee. I don't, yeah,
firearms and marijuana is not,
I want to be like fucking hyper diligent,
hyper aware on the point.
No fucking around.
You know the last thing you ever want
to be involved in is a firearm accident
that you could have prevented.
It's a good point.
I didn't even think fuck that angle. I
got no, I know guys who do it though.
They smoke weed and then go there.
Go fucking bow hunting.
But getting the tree stand, smoke a joint,
sit out there with nature. They like it.
Thrill. At least if you're in a tree
stand and you're shooting a bow and Arrow,
the likelihood of you shooting
yourself is very small.
The likelihood of you shooting somebody
else very small, you know? Yeah.
Cause he in the NGO probably high back
in the day when they were hunting,
they didn't have much marijuana here.
Not We, but they hit pay. Odious dieting.
They use that. But yeah, there's
probably some mushroom use going on too.
But I think they would use that stuff
to sort of like fucking post post,
you know hunt. They're kind
of like celebrate, celebrate
or something like that.
But the vikings, you know, used to use
mushrooms and go on Soda Zercher no,
not those guys. They
steroids different vikings.
Who's that fucking giant dude who
there's all these photos of this, some,
some football player. There was like
a bunch of memes with this guy, Steve.
You know what I'm talking about?
It was his steroid precursor. No,
I mean probably who the fuck knows? You
know? I don't know. Is it a college kid?
Is it college hit? Yeah, he's
in college. He's like, oh,
he's saying six eight to
90 or something like that.
I mean the people today are
so God damn freaky. Huge.
Yeah. We're present body
fat. It's just run like deer.
Yeah. This is the guy. What? Look at this.
This is not the right picture, but look,
there's one picture of this guy standing
around a bunch of other people and he
just like, Yo, what the fuck? How was that
guy? So yeah, that's the photo. That photo
right? Yeah. Yeah. The
size of that mother fucker.
That guy was created in a lab that doesn't
even look like a real person and the
non negative body fat.
What do you got going on? Making the
pitch picture bigger. Oh the, yeah,
that's not the f B. There's a full
photo of them. There it is. Yeah.
See if you can make that better. This
Twitter, Twitter doesn't. When you do,
when you try to enlarge a Twitter photo,
it doesn't let you do that.
For some reason. You go to a certain size
and then it blanks out on, yeah. Yeah.
He looks like a,
like a lab experiment.
You know when you go back and you look
like Jim Brown back when he was playing
Sean Oakman,
that's the the gentleman's name.
I will call him a gentleman from
now on. By the way, he's something,
some insane size and
he's still in college.
It just doesn't make any sense.
People are just way bigger now.
I don't know if it's hormones in the meat.
No.
12 year old girls with mustad
handled my various, look at this,
look at this mother fucker cheese.
Just
I fucking Christ. Probably a strong safety
toe. Look at the size of that guide.
It doesn't even look like a human look
how he's towering over the guys next to
him. Look at his arms. He said, yeah,
they're popping out of his shell. Well,
why is he have pants on?
They're not going to help pass a useless.
What the fuck? He doesn't have
pads on. Do what the fuck?
What the fuck and naughty. She got a
stomach like a cheerleader. Just, yeah,
those why.
I was thinking that the other day,
like how come do it never caught on
with guys to wear like a midriff exposed
shirts.
It's like girls wear those exclusively
like midriff in West Hollywood lately.
Yeah, with the tide and the
not in front. That's the best.
Like Ellie Mae fucking clamping
boulevard. Oh, the fucking Beverly
hillbillies. Yeah. Nobody, nobody fucked.
Back then you watched the
Beverly hillbillies. Nobody
ever, ever fucked Ellie Mae.
Who? Did she even go on a
date on that Shell? Yeah,
with Jethro brother. Then you had
the first lesbian in Hollywood.
I think it was mishandled away.
I thought it was Alice.
I think a heavily hillbillies. Alice
from the Brady was Alison, but I think,
oh Christ. Yeah. Christ.
Yeah. She played Texas.
She was a nose tackle before she goes.
She landed the role of Ellis.
See the copy. I'm stumbling over my own
friends and we're getting angry already.
Fucking Shit fucking on people. She
was good, but no, but ms Hathaway was,
but I think the Beverly hillbillies
predated the lady that worked at the bank.
Yes. There were always
kissing his ass because, yeah,
because Jed had all the money.
Yeah.
The one that Dennis Miller said when
he's talking about Bruce John, hey,
when did Bruce Jana Turner to
missions Hathaway from the best?
It's not the best reference,
but I see what he's going.
Oh, exactly. It wasn't, that smell is
a strange cat man. He is a strange guy.
Don't like them. I like him too.
I mean, I, I like him as a person.
I've talked to them, I enjoy
talking to him. But he,
nine 11 came along and that
guy just went flunking.
He took our right turn and hit that gas.
I was already there.
You were always there.
Fuck yeah.
Stuck out like a sore thumb
and Boston didn't I go, well,
Boston's a little right wing. I mean,
there's a lot of left wing in Boston,
but there's a lot of right wing too.
You're right.
It's so left that we used to
talk about this at Nick's.
It's so left wing that
it came full circle.
They started to have shit and
common like people from Southie and,
and you know, it was,
remember Barry Crimmins you
remember though, you know, um,
I was talking to bobcat this weekend.
Bobcat Goldthwait came to the UFC and I
got him and his daughter's boyfriend is
a big UFC fan.
I got him some tickets and hung out with
them and he just did a documentary on
Barry Crimmins and that's right.
I heard them talking about it.
It's pretty intense piece sick
now. Barry Wright is he, he,
he was a couple of years ago, they
had a benefit for him. Oh, I didn't,
I didn't know about that.
Yeah, but this was about, uh,
Barry was apparently you molested
as a child, as a young child.
And this, this is sort of like
explaining how we became this,
like sort of angry, curmudgeon,
right. Type into prep,
patently of fucking really deep
and intense documentary. And,
uh,
it's coming out,
it's gonna be on Sundance and there
they're going to come on the show in, um,
sometime either late January
or February, but, um, it's a,
it's a fucked up,
fucked up bobcat title to like call
me lucky or something like that.
Like I'll be like, I like, that's
what he, you know, he named the, uh,
the documentary, something along
those lines. He told me the title.
It was howling laughing, but yeah,
Barry Crimmins was like super left.
I remember hearing that him saying that
he came out one night and he would have
broke down on stage. It
stitches about that. Whoa.
That's what I remember hearing.
I don't think, I can't remember if I had
already moved to New York at that point,
but I remember somebody telling me second
hand that he like that he let it all
out on stage one night or something.
But you know,
left wing back then was a different
thing. Oh yeah. Hell yeah.
It was way more tolerant. Yeah,
it was way, way more tolerant or,
and now it's become a lot of
like shaming and call outs.
It's become this aggressive
tactic thing like the, the uh,
aggressively left wing in
your face about it, which is,
it creates conflict more than it resolves
anything. Absolutely. You know, I mean,
Barry was like,
he was like a pro union guy because he
believed that people should get good
wages. He bought American beer. He
would always drink a Budweiser stage.
I was a bar back. I used to carry
that. I carry a case of bud.
I was a bar back for like six
months in stitches. I'll refer.
I started comedy with
Suzy. Suzy. Remember Susie,
the manager of a stitches, she
was in that band. They had a,
a parody band where they walk like an
Egyptian without walk with an erection.
Harry can 40 was running it at
the town and but barrier. Right.
I used to bring a case of Budweiser and
you're right now we think back on it.
He was hiding something. He would
drink that case throughout the night.
That'd be maybe two left. I mean,
wow. In about them. You know,
I sit around after and he had a cooler
and he's the only guy that ever tip me as
a bar back. He was a kid, big walrus
mustache. He was kind of intimidating.
And what's funny is I know
it's like really critical.
He so I mean radical left wing,
but he used to make me laugh as hard
as any bunch and me tingle and tingle.
I mean the funny guy,
no doubt about it.
I always quote tingles
joke about Ronald Reagan.
This was when I was an open miker.
I saw him perform this cause when I was
an open mic or was right after the whole
Reagan Contra thing and went down,
I was like 1988 and right after Reagan was
out of office, they were, they were, uh,
he was on trial and they were asking
him, did you sell arms to Iran? He said,
I don't remember. I don't
recall. Mr President,
who you sent when you sell arms to
people who hate us, shut it down.
That is a perfect Boston Jimmy tingle
is this such a great line shot down?
That is a good tangle jog. Yeah, he
was good. He and he's another one.
He's like real left wing but reasonable
in his left wing. Absolutely.
You know,
it's like left wing now has become this
like super hyper fascist funks there's
like I've experienced,
I experienced it at a pretty hardcore
way when I came out again and I'm pretty
fucking left wing and a lot of issues
on gay rights, on gay marriage, on a,
a lot of different issues on
racial issues, but I also own guns.
I'm in the NRA.
I'm a lot a lot of like,
I feel like there's a lot of
credible issues on both sides.
But there was this guy who got a sex
change and then started fighting women in
MMA. I was like, get the fuck out of here.
And all these people were calling me
transphobic and big ed and all this crazy
shit and that's when I got really,
that's when I really experienced the full
understanding of what it means to be a
social justice warrior.
Right.
Anytime a man is critical of women,
anytime a man Shit's a woman, that guy
cause 10 bucks. That's
it. She has one arm,
we don't shit on them.
Shit on the ones for a thousand.
You don't even feel bad about it.
It's like we got, you got paid well,
but anytime a man is doing something
horrible against a woman or saying
something like that,
that guy becomes a misogynist less,
you're criticizing a transgender person.
See transgender is more
marginalized than women.
So a transgender guy who becomes
a girl now can fight women.
And if you criticize that,
you're criticizing a former guy
who's now a girl and that's like,
yeah,
it gets both
cause that,
right.
So he's fighting guys now at least he's
out what she is out of the closet or you
know, not, I shouldn't say
out of the closet. I said uh,
out and open about it because the first
two women she fought didn't know that
she used to be a guy. I saw some of this
on. It was fucking crazy. What's crazy?
His name is no need.
No need to get this captain
anymore fucking publicity
than she's already gotten
this. Just cause it. She had a hundred
youtube videos complaining about me.
But the bottom line dailies,
yeah, there's, there's two,
there's two schools about it. There's
transgender reassignment doctors who say,
no,
she's totally a woman's toe.
But then there's martial artists and
then a regular endocrinologist. They go,
Whoa, Whoa, hold on a second. Like,
yeah, talking about just regular sports.
And I'm talking about someone
who's competing and say,
you know, fucking madness,
like racing Renee Richards,
there was another one who was
on a mountain bike weight racer,
forgot riding a mountain bike racer who
dominated all the women in her first
professional event is
beating him like fucking 10,
15 seconds faster than everybody.
And it was like, what the fuck?
And these are like a lot of people like
encouraged her to get into, you know,
competing as a woman. And then, you know,
just the inherent differences of the
fucking male and female frame really get
highlighted when you watch somebody
beat the shit out of somebody who is a
natural born woman versus
someone who's becoming a woman.
He tells you certain
things you can't change.
Jodie, you remember, you remember
Super Foot Wallace? Fuck yeah, I do.
Do you remember when the woman went up
against him on why were all the sports?
No. Ah, why did she go wonder if it's
Stella around while it wasn't even,
can't be cause a kickboxing.
Yes, Bill. Super Fun.
I don't know what Billie Jean King and
the whole movement was in full swing and
this broad comes running
out and he fucking drops her
like a used rubber fucking
the first who's I came as a round house
or just a paunch probably a hook kick or
a punch because he had the,
he had the best hook kick and say,
I want to say it was a kick to the head.
Then they drag her back to a court and
they sit her up again and they send her
out again and he does it again. No
Way. Yes. Really map as a kid going,
what the fuck? Sharing. Oh,
there's a woman named Lucio Riker.
It was probably one of the best women
boxers of all time and she fought a guy
and it was like one of the
first, uh, men versus female.
She has fought a mediocre guy and she's
like a world champion that everybody
like Christy Martin was docket
are all these women were docker.
She wasn't going to kill that man.
We're the coal miner's daughter.
This does this,
this Lucy Lucier Riker chick was arguably
one of the best female boxers of all
time.
Got fucking lit up like a Christmas
tree by this dude and knocked dead just
womp.
He caught her with a punch
and just fucking turned the
lights out in Georgia and
she face planted. It was ugly
because you know, you're,
you're watching a guy beat the
shit out of a chair. It's just,
it doesn't matter if they're the same
weight class, it doesn't matter if they,
they have the same amount of body mass.
It's a different structure. Well, I,
Chris Rock said, yeah, you know, we
were talking about that. He goes, yeah,
you still have a hundred and he
still had 105 pound chin though.
That's the deference or whatever.
Well, they can definitely,
men can definitely take punches better
for the most part when it's guys that are
built much more slender and feminine,
but this one woman who
used to be a man is not,
is not built feminine. You know, you get
man shoulders and fucking man hands, man,
hands hit harder, man. Shoulders are
wider. The whole deal. It's just,
but the point being until then I had
not experienced the full impact of the
progressive movement, the full
aggressive response. Totally a logically.
I'm like, look, we're just, we're not
talking about her right to be a woman.
I fully support that.
You want to,
I wouldn't know what it was like
to be born a man as a problem.
I fully support you changing
your, your sex. No problem
at all. Change your gender.
No problem at all.
I have no problem with,
I'll call you whatever the fuck you want,
but if you beat the shit out of my sister,
I'm probably going to come out to you.
This is going to be honest with you.
I try to be tolerant until I find out
that you did not disclose the fact that
used to be a man and my sister's in the
fucking hospital cause you're shinned
her in the head. You know? It's
like this is a different world.
You're talking about. You're talking
about the world of combat sports.
That's my world and I'm
telling you right now,
there's a big goddamn difference between
the way a man hits a bag and the way a
woman hits the bag. He watched the
difference between the impact. I'm not,
I don't know how much gets taken away
by that sex change, but not enough.
Not Enough. That's right. Just this,
just, just too much. That's good.
More out the dead, which you can't.
You know what? You can't change, dude,
that you can't change the size of
the fists. You can't change the,
the the you mean? Yeah, the
frame, the frame. If you,
that woman dies and a thousand years
now scientists dig up her body,
they're going to go, oh, there's
a dude that's a dude skeleton.
There is going to know that it
was transgender. It's a woman.
They're not going to know that. They're
going to say, this is a male skeleton,
looks at the hips. That's,
those are male hips. They,
that was a boundary that even
feminists used to stay away from,
but now they seem to be
pushing that. Like I, I was,
I was a Gotham a couple of years.
I've got to fight breaks.
I had nothing to do with me on stage.
Like two tables get into it.
And there was women right in the middle
of it swinging over what? I Dunno, they,
someone was being loud and another
table complaint and those boyfriends and
girlfriends at the table. Then they
just started fucking swinging on it.
And there was a girl right in
the middle. She's trying to
hit the doorman and the other
doorman came over. Whoa.
Fucking knocked out the doorman.
She know he popped her. Yeah,
that's what I'm saying. Yeah.
Or he at the Dorman yesterday.
You don't fuck around at Gotham. Those
were all former cops. It's exactly Pfizer,
a big fucking Irish squared jaw sandwiches
that have knocked a lot of fucking
head's loose.
Yeah.
And these chicks right in the middle
fucking throat trying to throw haymakers
because they bought into this
shit. Yeah. You know what I mean?
They're going a little too far with it.
Did you see the woman trying
to play football? No. On the
Internet? No. Look it up,
but it was an indoor league or
an arena league or whatever.
It's like first and goal from the five
yard line. She's a female. Run them.
And I don't mean like a big, because
I'm a woman. She just thinks she's fast.
She tries to, yeah, they tried to run
her off tackle like four times and she,
each time she gets hit more bro.
Even how it was like cringing,
I don't even know.
I don't even know her name.
It was like an indoor league or
arena league, but it said, you know,
she was like the first one,
first female to play in a pro game.
That wasn't a kicker. Physical equality
is nonexistent. It's just nonexistent.
And it's definitely, it's
not even existent inside
the genders. Male you like,
there's certain fucking men. Oh, it
just guys who fight in the UFC. Oh,
you're just like this guy,
Hector Lombard.
There's fucking freak of nature of this
Cuban Olympian judo player who's just
fucking knockout artists. You watch
him fight and you're like, Whoa,
homos is unfair that he
fights regular people
even though they're bald.
They're all 170 pounds.
That's a fucking different hundred
and 70 pounds. But at least there,
I mean it's, there's no fair when it comes
to that shit and that's part of what,
what it is to be a champion.
Like what is this five foot,
230 pound female running back plays a
professional football game. Watch the,
oh no, she's still alive. All right.
Two guys that knocked her out.
Why would she do that?
She was taking shots like I've let
say, please pray the play. That's it.
And they give the bottle
like three times in a row.
Are we going to get pulled from youtube?
Let's see.
Let's,
we'll edit this ladies and gentlemen.
And if we get pulled from Youtube
Jamille just edit that peanut.
I think Google it. What's the name of it?
Uh, the, the, it's called five foot two.
It's on Daily Mail.
Five foot two 130 pound female running
back plays in professional football game.
But I think the video is actually
pulled from this website.
So really by her husband.
Yeah,
cause this is not playing
the fucking United Nations
as a crime against humanity.
Right. Here's a picture
though. Oh God. Look at her
getting smashed. That's not it.
That's not it though. That's not her.
Well that might be, that's it. That's the,
that's the clip. Oh, here we go.
Jesus Christ.
That was her about to go in.
They just smashed her. You got up. She
gets a round of applause for getting up.
Not
Dead Up.
Congratulations.
She's not dead.
They give her the ball three times
in a row and each kid is more savage.
I'm sitting there going, what the
fuck? But she's tough as nails. She,
she didn't go off the pill.
That's hurt. You see your flaws.
You see it go flying through the air
through her. Don't, let's not watch this.
I don't want to watch that. Yeah.
When people can I laugh crazy.
Why would you laugh? It makes me
sad. Big check. Trying to play again.
I have daughters. I don't want it
to be that stupid. All they woman,
you wouldn't let him do that, would you?
I put them, I can. I can't control them.
They become adults.
They can do whatever the fuck you
can give him that mine offering shit.
You though show you got
to see this last one,
this humongous Chi.
Here we go. Watch this.
She's got the ball. Oh,
fucking Christ. Look
at, she pops right up.
That's a tough chick. Oh yeah.
Oh, she's probably played,
I guess before you got to,
you got to juice
even she's juicing, you know, God. I mean,
you'd have to juice for so long that
you actually became a man. We had a, um,
a guy in the podcast that used to be a
woman and became a man, a buck angel.
She's Kinda Belamine.
Well, when she was a woman,
she was built like slender and now
he's a man and he's pretty thick.
And He, at one point in time we got
to like one 85. He was fucking Yolk.
But you said it was like too
much pressure on the joints,
like because he just fucking bang
and testosterone doing dead lifts,
but this, you know, there's
only so much that changes.
It doesn't change the size of your fucking
face and the size of your hands and
all that stuff gets smashed. You know?
How does, let me ask you a question.
How does Stallone, he's 68
he's still Joseph, right? Yeah.
I watch these movies and he's ripped.
He's more than 68 now.
I think he's almost 70 I'm, I'm, I'm ready
to juice. Yeah, you should do it. Yeah.
It's testosterone replacement
therapy. Where Ellie? Yeah.
Do it. Give me a name of the
doc. Damn, I'm good. Sherry.
Physique of fucking buddy Epson. Yeah.
Listen, it makes it the Beverly Hills Rep.
The bottom line still alone in 68 yeah.
He's my canary in a coal mine.
As long as I fucking guy's alive. We're
all good. I'm telling you that. Look it,
there's a lot of science involved in it.
And if you go to the right doctor, right,
you make sure that you get your level,
your blood levels checked
on a regular basis.
It's not any more dangerous than aging.
Aging's fucking terrible.
A great point agent gets you.
No matter what you do,
everybody dies from aging
and the people are like, oh,
that's eventually going to kill
you. Oh, like unlike life. Well,
I'm going to get cheated out of a month.
Listen, you know it's, he's got a good,
a new Rambo. He's doing
a new fucking rhino. No,
just calling it laugh.
Last blood.
Somebody said is that somebody
made a menopause joke about it.
I forget who it was.
Somebody said that already
has never been the fucking [inaudible]
68 year old guy that looks like him. No,
I mean, my wife says I'm in love with
them and that kind of now I like Stellato.
He still sucks me in and don't like
those. Look at that. The fuck out of here.
We have that picture of him. Will you that
picture of, that's recent. Look at that.
That's recent. How is that
possible man? Testosterone. What?
That's what's missing from old people.
So my GNC pills, that's a test us Ronnie,
not cutting it does a bunt. Those,
those help a little do that, you know,
you know it helps a lot is I'm dead
lifts and squats on that hill sprints and
anytime you do something that's like
compound exercises that require your body
to like put out a lot of energy,
like big bursts, evangelists,
those force your endocrine system to
fire up because your body's like this
motherfucker is going to be
lifting weights like he's going to,
he's going to do this all the time.
We got to produce a lot more
hormones than we regularly are.
But if you just sit around in a
fucking office and you don't exercise,
your testosterone levels are just,
your body only does what
it has to do this right?
That's why people get muscle
atrophy when they don't work out.
Your muscles shrink
because your body's like,
we don't need things that happens to
young people. And if you don't work out,
your body is like,
we don't need this.
Well that's the same
thing when you get old.
If you get old and you're not lifting
weights, your bone density decreases.
A lot of shit happens. My, my
giant stuff, I did p 90 x, right?
I did, you know, he's supposed to do it
for 90 days. I did it for like 11 months.
I got obsessed with, whoa.
And I dropped like 10 pounds,
which is all I wanted to drop. I was
in like this, I, I did this like, uh,
it ended about a year and a half ago,
but I kept doing it.
You only supposed to do and there's a
reason you're only supposed to do it
because it's kind of tough on your joints.
So I did it for like 11 my Austin.
I get up my,
my knees a clicking
and it's not because it's not because
the p nights, because I abused it. Right.
You know, I mean, there's a lot of jump
acts is a lot of stuff that people say.
It's kind of out of fashion now. Uh, well,
not out of fat, but you know, I mean, um,
I just not for a guy in his
fifties and I may, yeah. Well,
there's some people that have
some good ideas about like,
and limitations are a lot of times based
on injuries, like, oh, this guy got it,
he hurt his back. Well, don't do that
anymore and you won't hurt your back.
There's a lot of ideas that people have,
but it's,
it's all about knowing your body,
knowing how much stress you put on your
body and giving your body plenty of
recovery time and then giving your
body the right nutrients to recover.
Like fish oil, vitamin D, protein,
a full range of multivitamins. This is
super important for your body and food,
like eating the right foods.
That's, that's very important.
Like all the vitamins in the world,
they're not going to help you if you're
eating fucking cheeseburgers every day.
Who else did you eat
healthy? Oh yeah. Yeah,
a lot of salmon, chicken. Let a protein,
vegetables, that's me. You know,
just enough carbs to fuel
me. And it worked. Yeah, it
worked. Fucking awesome. Oh,
you did everything because you get your
heart rate goes through the roof and,
and uh, no, there's no digest.
Abused it. I, I got it.
I had never done anything that worked
like that since I was in my twenties and I
played football in college. I was the
best shape I was in and I was like,
Holy Shit. And that's what we were doing
back then. We were doing, you know,
a lot of plyometrics and right.
And that's
what we did in college to get, and I
was in great condition, but I couldn't,
I was doing it six times a week and
he's supposed to stop at the 90 days.
I didn't know you're supposed to stand up.
I just thought it was 90 days.
You're in your 50s you are,
you know,
I mean if you're 25 you can
fucking do it for three years.
I'm sure the guy that does it is like 50
oh, he's older than that now Tony. Yeah,
Tony Go. Great shape. I know.
Do you know,
isn't it?
There's another one that you can
do that's called the extreme,
a kettlebell cardio workout by this guy,
Keith Weber does not.
No jumping and no, none of
that stuff. It's all just want,
I do it with a 30 little bell.
He saw that out there.
I tried to pick it up and I got, well,
I'm done with that shit. That's 70 pounds,
so that's a heavy one.
Just this one was a light one.
It's just a full cardio
workout. It's fucking, you
pick up a 35 pound Kettlebell,
it feels like nothing, but after
like a man, Holy Shit. You're like,
how much time is this going? It's
a 45 minute workout. Oh my God,
20 minutes in your fucking legs are
on fire. Your lungs are on fire,
but it's very low stress and your joint
because there's not a lot of weight and
it's not like no,
no jumping or anything like that.
I fucking love that workout and do
it all the time. It's fantastic,
but it's like one of those ones. He's
doing it so you do it, you follow along.
Those are the best ones. That's
what's good about that. P Nine zero x.
It's like exactly. Do what they're
doing and then you know it's over.
When you're done, you
show up. Yeah, that's,
I'm his fucking just actually doing
shit like so many people like, ah,
I want to get in shape
the fucking guy that's all just
fucking do it. Nobody does it.
It just fucking talk about it, talk
about it. He said that and one a,
and one of the things he goes,
just show up and hit play and it,
that actually set off the thing in
my hand, no matter how Shitty I felt,
I'd gone on and go,
yeah. You know, I always
give myself advice like, uh,
like something like a lot of times
when I land somewhere I'm like, oh,
I don't want to go to the gym, you know?
And I'm like, oh, come on pussy man up.
And then I tell myself like,
all right,
I pretend like I'm talking to me and I
call myself a pussy and then I just go.
But I always feel better when I do,
you know,
it's like knowing when you feel like
shit because you're getting sick and
knowing when you feel like shit,
just because this mother fucker gets up.
I'll tell you what that
mother fucker gets up.
He put that picture up. Brian,
I read an article. He said
he, when he was, you know,
when he was doing the, the, the,
uh, the, uh, expendables, no,
the first blood Rambo, he was so
obsessed with working out. He'd go,
he'd be out in south beach,
shit paste,
and then go right to the jump drunk
at three in the morning. Really? Yeah.
When he was drunk, he didn't
stay alone with workouts. Yes.
He said he was obsessed with it.
I didn't even know he got drunk.
That's what he said. Well,
he said he was at bars.
I'm guessing that's what he was doing
and he'd go right to the frigging gym.
That's hilarious.
Three in the morning.
Well that's if you fall the rock,
fall, the rocks Instagram page.
If you ever want to feel like a lazy fuck,
follow the rocks Instagram page.
He'll like fucking fly somewhere at five
o'clock in the morning and he's like,
touchdown 5:00 AM gym five 30.
And he's like the gym doing fucking,
sorry,
has the kettlebells,
kettlebells. Yeah. Yeah, he's on
it. I'll fly to a hotel in the gym.
I could see it from my room. I won't go
to it now. Just stare at it. It's old.
It's a fucking, it's gonna get me
hurt. So Nautilus, they're updated.
They're bad for your joints. Pull that
picture up. Look at this motherfucker.
70 years old of hilarious.
Yeah.
Look how he's looking out the window.
You move to shoot somebody
who killed somebody as well.
It's going to frigging nine pack. He's an
actor. Look at, he's awesome. That's true.
If I knew somebody, you know, if I
knew 12 main people going to see me,
how to actually put in
the time. Yeah. I mean,
but when it's my wife who gives a fuck?
Yeah. Listen Bitch, you gonna suck it.
And whether you like it or not,
we're getting divorced.
You decide you want to be lonely.
Ah, rude. That's a great idea.
I never thought about that. You use
divorced, like suck it or divorce.
You're not a good idea. That's
why you're not married. Yeah.
I say, yeah. I say something ridiculous
and he's like, what a great idea.
I'm joking around. He's like, hey,
this is doctor. Let me write this down.
When did you get married five years
ago. Was it fun? I know you get kids,
but I don't know yet. For some reason
I didn't think you were married.
I held off for a while. I think marriage
is ridiculous, but I'm not going to wear,
I have kids. I love having kids. I
even enjoy being married, but I don't.
I think the idea of a legal contract
with the state and illegal more,
more ridiculous is the idea that you bring
a bunch of people that you don't even
know and if you decide to break up,
they decide where all the money goes
and you have to split things up.
And I've had some friends that have gone
through some absolutely fucking brutal
divorces. Will you understand what
divorce really is? It's a business.
I mean the,
the,
the marriage system in this country and
the encouragement is involved in getting
marriage. Getting married is about
selling diamonds. That's a big one.
And then distribution of assets, which
a big part of go to the legal system.
That's when people don't think about
Phil Hartman was the first one to fucking
the tro turned me onto that. But
how about the flip side, you know,
illegitimate kids and all that and know,
well,
the solution to the family
and how that turns out, well,
what's legitimate and what's not.
I mean,
if you're together and you're
the father and she's the mother,
you fucking jump over a broom. Like they
didn't roots and you say, we're married.
You know,
I have friends that have kids that they,
they changed their names and
they're not married. You know,
they decide we don't need to
do this legally. You know,
I have friends that got married like on
a Lark, like they're not really married.
They got married by a
friend, you know, like dude.
And they went through a whole
ceremony, dug Stan hope, did that.
He got married and was like a fake.
And then like when she went crazy,
he was like, well, I guess, uh,
let's not be married anymore.
They just don't have to go to court. I
didn't understand. Help. Got Married.
You got married. While that
wasn't real, it wasn't real.
It's just like they did everything
except signing the actual papers.
They wear the rings or whatever. If he
went to court, if she took them to court,
I bet she could file. Yeah, I
bet. Back then they were together.
She get all his suits. Yeah. She would get
all those fucking goofy suits he wears.
Isn't there like a law, if you live
with somebody for over seven years,
that's a domestic partner or that could
be kind of law, common law. Marriage.
That's right. Is that an
all state? I don't think so.
I think it varies state by state,
but California, it's definitely, uh,
it exists in California and there's also
a thing about being married more than a
certain amount of time. I have a friend
who was married for 12 years in, uh,
you know, fucking towards the end. It was
brutal. We couldn't deal with anymore.
No kids broke up with her,
has to pay alimony for the
rest of her life forever.
She apparently, because he paid
for her for 12 years. I mean,
she's like 49, 50. She might live, he's
paying him. No, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no. He's paying forever.
Forever. He's paying a forever.
They were married when she was 30
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
This is California divorce law.
Talking about America.
When you go,
it's the People's Republic of California.
When you'd go through a certain amount
of years of marriage in California,
you are obligated. If you are the
guy who's, was it the caretaker?
I don't know how to describe it. If you're
the guy who's got the money with it,
with a friend, be Kurt Russell. No, it's
different guy. What was he doing? He,
Curtis was never married and never
got married again because of that.
Goldie Hawn. Well, they both have
money though. My friend was married.
His wife was just fucking
getting her nails done,
bringing her little fucking
showed a tiny dog, get it washed.
He has to pay her for
the rest of her life.
He's married now to another woman and
he pays her exorbitant amounts of money
every month, and she lives in his
old house in the fucking Palisades.
It's sweet house,
and she moved her boyfriend in.
And when you're living with a man,
then it's supposed to be, you know, he,
he's not supposed to pay anymore.
So he brings an investigator
into the situation.
The investigator goes
and they check the house.
The guy moves out when
the investigator comes,
he's around the corner with a fucking
u haul. As soon as they leave,
comes back around my shit back. They go
through this little dance where they do,
if she gets married again,
he doesn't have to pay her anymore.
But then she'd lose out on hundreds of
thousands of dollars a year. I mean,
I think he pays or something like six
or 700 grand a year. Well that's why,
and I'm not saying this is justified, but
that's why a lot of guys snap. Oh yeah.
I mean, same with all the,
uh, you know, child custody
thing. Like you know, it all,
it's all favor towards the mom and
that case and guys fucking snap. Well,
in some cases it's justified,
but they do, uh, the, the,
the systems are fucked up because first
of all, these people don't know you.
So if you go into court and you know,
it's everyone's trying to present their
argument like they're the perfect person.
I am the perfect husband. I was
the perfect dad. I, you know,
my wife is a crazy bitch. You know,
I was the perfect mom, my husband,
they weren't there. Yeah. I've
also had friends that their um,
their wives when they're breaking up,
we'll file a restraining order and say
that he was threatening and being abusive.
And if it's just you
and her alone that she,
they can say all kinds
of crazy shit and that's
a guy would snap. Well, I mean,
if you're going to ruin my life,
I have a friend who was a woman who was
getting divorced and her lawyer advised
her to do that and she was
like, what? Like she couldn't
fucking blue. She's like,
no, he's not violent, I'm not
going to do that. But she was like,
look at a little favor you in
court, you know, say that, you know,
say that he was abusive. Say that he
threatened you and you can, you know,
and he likes phrase it in a way
where he wasn't suggesting it.
He was saying one of the best ways to
ensure you know favor with the court is if
your husband was abusive.
Has he been abusive as he ever
said anything violent to you?
You know [inaudible] like and she's
like, are you insinuating? He's like,
well I'm just saying that if
you did that and she's like,
stop and I'm not going to do, have you,
have you seen that movie gone girl? Yes.
Holy Shit. That was kind of a good example
of that whole little bit good. Maybe.
Fuck Yeah Dude, you haven't seen it
now cause it seems like a chick flick.
It seems like it. It's,
it's weird. It's it.
I can't get past the hall.
It's the opposite of a chick flight.
Well it is. It's to me. I Dunno.
I have my own take.
I can't watch too much shit out of holiday
without seeing that the fucking angry
feminists head raring. It's fucking face
and everything. Yes. It was just an x.
Do you see a much hate
if you listen to the,
there was an unbelievably well written,
but yeah,
but that's a hateful
woman who wrote that Shit.
She hates men with a fucking patch,
but then they can justify it
at the end by going, well,
the woman's the crazy bitch in the movie.
That's what they do. Or alert. Listen,
don't say any more because people,
if you haven't seen that movie,
it's good fucking mood.
What happens in the end? No,
I've watched it in a hope
to get out and it ready.
I watched it in a hotel room in Vegas.
I was just like fucking by
myself and I was like, Eh,
I don't want to go to bed and
see what's on TV. He was like,
one o'clock in the morning,
I'm gonna Watch this till I fell asleep.
10 minutes in them fucking white
knuckle and the pill. What the
fuck? Yeah. But it was
so slick on and I was,
the dialogue is so slick and I'm like,
people really talk like that, but,
but the venom and the hatred towards men,
that's what I was getting out of it. I,
this woman had you listening,
you have to sleep in a hotel room.
I had two pots of coffee. Me, I was
sitting a foot from the TV yelling at it.
Go on. This broad is vicious.
Well but it was really,
really mean and well written and she's
got books out. Her last name is Flynn.
Apparently the book is really good.
Apparently the bullet is more complex.
It's more of like a murder mystery.
Whereas in the movie,
you know they're condensing it down to
two hours or whatever the hell it was.
But he didn't see like it the
way she was categorizing guys.
You know,
his idea of a fantasy would be a fucking
no reality show marathon and with his
hand down his pants,
you haven't said Shit like that.
I bought a woman and a fucking bold
please it drill yet of Hollywood
and all. But I just felt like they
were telling a story and you know,
given the scenario without telling what
the movie's about, it totally made sense.
I mean, you know, it makes sense,
but it's also coming from, you know,
it's a woman writing that shit down.
It's coming out of her filthy hope
and a, and if a guy ever
did the equivalent, you
couldn't get the movie made,
it wouldn't get green lit. I'm
just saying, I want to quality.
If you're going to be
a fucking Douche bag,
I want the right to be a Douche
bag back. Well, it used to be,
they used to be a horse.
Mack woman and movies,
Cary grant movies and shit happened in
real life. Mac. Well, how about, you know,
who were the, uh, uh, who sticks the
grapefruit, his wife's face? Archie bunker
who sticks a grapefruit as well
as whole movie. Yes. I'm huck.
You can't believe I'm going. I'm going.
I'm talking about the caffeine. Yeah.
Don't hurt your eyes. Um,
Cagney James Cagney. Oh really?
Yeah.
He goes,
I wish you were a wishing well and
you'd fucking sink or somebody sticks a
grapefruit. His wife's face at
the kitchen table. It's beautiful.
I played on a loop, but
it would be, I mean,
I wish you, you know, it's, it's
going too far the other way now.
It's all you could smack women in the
face and they would kiss you afterwards.
That was, those days were
different. What was it?
Who's going on back then where you could
just smack women was zero line like
dumb and beating Bartow county.
Is that what was going on? Yeah,
the blood into this feminist horse shit.
They're going to to follow themselves.
Yeah, but I mean, why was the guy
hitting her in the first place?
How about just have a conversation? Burnt
his eggs? I mean, come on, let's be, no,
I don't know.
Of course Guy Nicholas,
how dare you. Oh my
God. This is horrendous.
You're going to come after you
and Nick Dipaolo the feminists.
They're not going to come to your shows
anymore. No, exactly as I would hope.
They started picketing.
Great. He'll go down.
Wish she'd stop again. Watching. Hi.
We're here with emotion. Well, can
I tie a buck at the end? Thank you.
Whoa.
Maybe found someone you like better.
Oh Shit. Oh my God.
That's all she said is maybe you
found someone you liked better.
That was fucking palms
are in the face of it.
That was hard for the actual realize.
I didn't realize it was that hard either.
You know where I saw that on the soprano's
Tony Soprano's watching that movie at
home. I think it's public
enemy or something and uh,
that's where I first saw that and I go,
Holy Shit. How'd they get away with it?
Jesus Christ. Look at his
face kind of. Well, it's like,
you know who I go, Ooh. Slapped.
You know who wouldn't it
godfather across the face. Yeah.
That was like a palm strike.
Yeah. That was crazy. Yeah.
That was not just like a most of the face.
He had some like some snap to it.
It was the heel of the hand. Yeah, that
hurts. I'm going to show a different take.
That really did look rough for them.
The one I remember, I kick that bad.
That was horrible.
I'm with you on that one.
He was a real quick, all she said
was maybe a final time. I'm better.
I'm only have files on your right.
Yeah. She's being fairly reasonable.
Yeah. She wasn't even screaming. See,
but that's just it. 10 years ago. You
probably saw that and was like, yeah,
that she deserved it,
but we're all getting the side
in the last 10 DXC years ago,
Brian Movies from 50 fucking years.
That's a long time ago.
More than 50 years ago.
That movies from like the 50s right?
Wasn't that maybe even maybe even 40 yeah.
Well,
James Cagney public enemy,
I don't even know if that's
public and girls always had that,
that old school hair, that old school.
That way we like that Fay ray had,
when king cotton picked her up,
right.
That was before flat irons and they also
had like fluffy shit around the end of
their sleeves. Like that was super
common. Keys fisting a poodle.
Give your wife showed up at the dinner
table and she was wearing a shirt like
that. You'd be like, what the fuck
are you wearing? That? Sure, sure.
How about his pajamas? It's what
John are. Excellent cap guy.
Mike Brady snapping.
It's like what?
You were in jail when you
breaking rocks with a hammer.
1931 public enemy. 1931 yeah. Oh my God.
I think that was it. I think
that's public enemy. Yeah.
Social media back then was a newspaper.
I mean there was no one, you know,
social media between people. Shit. There
was nothing. Nobody had a voice back then,
you know, and a nice, it was quiet.
But it's interesting because you could
kind of could shape society with movies
like a movie like that where you
see James Cagney hit a chicken,
the face with a grapefruit.
That would be imitated by people
who went to see that movie. Yeah.
You don't think that happens now
godfather? Oh yeah, it definitely does.
But at least now you have like people
that counter that like this is horse shit.
This, this gone girl was fucking feminist
tropes. Bullshit. You know? Or this,
this gone grows.
It shows you the know the misogynistic
patriarchal society that we looked at
because arguments, people can have their
own sites and debate it. Back then,
you know,
you watched it,
chick got hit with a grapefruit
and then you went home and you hit,
your wife had a great fruit. Now
you hit her with a Panini. I mean,
how many people have watched movies
and thought that's how to behave?
I saw this in a movie, so
this is what you do. I mean,
it's gotta be pretty fucking comment.
Well,
just look at all the Scarface tee shirt,
Scarface.
How many he has a role model.
Huh?
Is there ever been a fucking movie where
a guy was like more of an anti hero
that became like a Jew?
Never write a drug dealer murderer was
coked out of his fucking mind became like
an iconic cultural figure. No. I know it
says something about where we're headed,
but everybody loved that movie. I fucking
loved that movie and I didn't love him.
I wouldn't wear them fucking get my
kid a tee shirt with his face on it.
But yeah, that's crazy. You see little
five year old kid with a scarf or a shirt.
You're like, what? Kids? Like,
where's the fucking face patient?
Their money. Then you'll get the
power. Then you'll get the push
to that bad guy leaving
the restaurant like shit,
I know Joe was doing a breath. I'm
putting mine away. That was embarrassed.
I was a good fucking movie. It was
a good fucking movie. How about me?
When I go to see that,
I go to see at the date came out and uh,
so it was really crowded at the theater
and this is my hometown and Danvers.
I sneaked down by the,
by the ropes,
waiting for the doors to open so I can
run in and sit in the front of the next
showing the door is open. What do
I see him falling in the pool? Oh,
I just went into denial.
I'm like, that's not him.
That was just probably some side
character that's not, didn't know.
That's what I saw. That's terrible.
That ruins everything. Spoiler alert.
I'm happy. Double spoiled.
That's a fucking spoiler.
Rowanda was one,
but he became a weird guy and they're
like later in his movies he became like
this real overact kind of tied
to big, too big. Like where like,
you know, it just didn't,
didn't matter like he was,
it was like always like just trying to
sell shit material or something like that.
I just wasn't good anymore. But you
go back to back to dog day, afternoon.
You know how fucking good was he? That was
a movie about a transgender Guy, right?
Who's got to try and get money for his
friend to get a section. That's right.
They were robbing a bank and it wasn't
based on true story. I don't think so.
I think so.
That was a great fucking Larry with,
he was fucking good back
then. God Damn, he was good.
It's a Kim and I watched some
fucking trailer for a movie.
I almost watched it for a goof.
It was Deniro and Matt
Travolta. No, that was,
that was terrible. That was kind
of cute. Oh good Lord Kenny.
I really did. I bet you
did. Worse than that farm.
Worse than that was a deniro and Travolta
Travolta plays a Russian hitman and
deniros like fucking CIA guy.
It was one word. Oh my God.
He's the worst fucking trailer. Like
you watched the trailer and you're like,
who green lit this horrible piece of
shit that I'm watching here. Yeah.
And it doesn't,
what happens when the,
when the two characters in the movie of
that famous that you're watching Dinair
we'll chase. Yeah. Travolta. You're
not watching a Russian guy chip. Yeah,
me with a shitty Russian accent.
Terrible killing season. Oh, it's so bad.
But like Deniro over the last few years
it seems like they just give him movies
and he's like, oh, I don't do that.
Fuck it. Pay My fee. I'll fucking do it.
Yeah. Even that poster looks bad for
that. Maybe like, oh, that's so bad. Dude.
It's so bad.
I would say the Amish beard,
I would say play the Empty Ami.
I would say play the trailer,
but we'll definitely get kicked off
of youtube for that fucking trailer.
That puts us in hunting and central park.
Is that each other?
It's such a bad movie. You remember
when uh, Deniro did that movie with um,
the like he did like a fantasy movie,
like one of those fucking wizards
source for a movie with, um,
what the hell is her name?
I'm the chick from
the two other though the
Sharon Stone.
It was,
I think it was her and Sharon Stone and
Deniro and some awful fucking Unicorn
wizard movie.
While was that movie that
was called paycheck? It was,
I mean,
what is he spending his money on?
How much money is that guy have heat will.
It's funny because not as much as you
think because there was a whole article a
few years ago about him having
money problems. Really? Yeah,
he and he just bought a bunch
of property upstate New York and
it is started the US look at it as,
fuck. I don't even remember that.
He's a wizard or something.
I don't even remember that kind
of 7.7 and IMD be fuck you.
I am DB.
Find out what's showgirls
has on item 9.7 that's,
that's a legitimate right.
Good movie because it's so bad. Which
one? Show showgirls. Yeah. Legitimately.
What was her name like chicken.
Elizabeth spoke 4.5 that's it.
Outrageous.
That's about right.
But how does that one have a 7.7 that's
7.7 is almost fucking eight you know,
eight is almost nine. Nine is almost
perfect. Right? That's horse shit.
That's stupid. Train
movies. 95% on rotten. What?
Train movie as Snow Piercer. Oh
yeah. That doesn't make any sense.
Did you see that thing Snowpiercer?
No. It's one of those indie movies.
People like movies that were made for
like 50 bucks when they find out movies
were made cheap and it was made in house.
Oh,
these guys made it and you know they,
they all got together. They chipped in,
they started, they got a Kickstarter.
Everybody gets real excited. They did it.
Marin's garage
where he does his podcast while he was
doing it. Then we took behind them.
Yeah. It will say they do it in
the background. I don't know.
I didn't even know about this movie.
What did you know that there
was a sequel to whatever.
That one is called little Fockers
where it's just the little bases.
That's right.
What the fuck are you serious Hoffman?
He did meet the Fockers movies. He's been
cashing in. He really has. You're right.
It wasn't bad in the first one
though. The first one wasn't that? No,
that was funny. Yeah. It's
actually pretty funny. But he's,
what was the movie he played?
There was a fuck.
Um, it was a movie that
Deniro did. Resa. Goddamn,
and I've got to go to the Deniros
IMD last Vegas. The family. Oh,
the family wedding. Silver linings
playbook. No, no, no. There was a good,
it was actually a fairly decent
fucking movie. Limitless.
He played practical magic.
He played some mob guy and um,
that's it. The one he said,
the family family.
I think it's that.
I think that's it. The Good Shepherd
family. The family was the family.
It's kind of a spoof on the
mob. No, it was a spoof. Fuck.
God dammit. How'd the Godfather,
I'm not going to know this. Mm.
Not Women
List. Not killer elite. Not being
freelancers now. Big Wedding.
No killing seat. No. That was the one
we just talked about. Who Cop land,
which was an American house. What
the fuck was American hustle? Oh,
it was American hustle was in American
hustle. Louie was in that, yeah.
He was in American hustle to narrow
was, yes. Yes. He was good in that.
I forget.
He was good in that movie.
They were trying to set
somebody up and um, he,
he happened to know a Arabic and the
guy was playing like a fake Arab.
There was an undercover cop was
playing a fake Arab. Oh yeah. Yeah.
He was actually good in that.
It's like one of the rare American hustle.
That was a good, okay. That
movie has 7.3 American hustle,
which was a great movie.
7.3,
those fucking twats they're playing
with our emotions and I never saw it.
How does that have a 7.3 in the,
it's a good fucking movie.
American hustle is like an eight or a
nine. It's a really good movie. And a,
what's her name? Jennifer Lawrence. Oh,
good Lord. She's hot and that movie. Yeah,
that was a good place. What a good
kid she is, Huh? What a good kid.
Good kid. Uh, goods coming
out of that leak. Uh, I don't,
I don't have any problem with that
beautiful girl, but yeah, I mean that's a,
that's one of the rare movies that
he's done over the last few years.
It was actually good, but that's what
happens, man. That's a weird world.
Do you know that world of the aging
older actor guy who used to be the iconic
movie? There he is. Yeah. He played
some fucking God, I forgot about that.
That's right. That's right. He
was good in it too. It was scary.
He was legitimately scary.
You give him a good role,
he could still knock it out
of the park. Oh yeah. Yeah.
He's an act that that
a bar. Yeah. It's just,
I guess it's like not that many good
roles for a guy like that or you know,
they'd go, hey, we've got this movie.
It's independent. Is it stopped click B?
That's right. Yeah. He's like,
listen, this is Andy, my ass.
Dinero for Christ's sake.
I got a mortgage. But you mentioned,
it's funny. That's an interesting thing,
but real successful,
famous act as and they get older
and then there's a movie right now,
right with Michael Keaton
about that very thing.
You just see that z birdman yet
I heard it's really good. Good.
Find out what that has on IMD.
Be fucking shitbag few website.
Yeah, it's those guys, man,
they get to a certain age.
It's like there's not a lot of roles
and women it's way worse because women
aren't even scary. 8.7
damn. Birdman respect.
Yeah. Um, like a woman like, like Faye
Dunaway, they get to a certain age,
good fucking luck. Tro He got
wasn't a double standard. Yeah.
Especially if it's money, you know, it's
like a, like a big money movie. Like the,
you know,
she was on major league movie star,
probably making ridiculous amounts
of money at that time in her day.
And then you get to a certain Angela,
hey, we've got nothing for you. You know,
you want to work. Like Robin Williams
was talking about that before he died.
He was talking about why he went back
to television and they were saying,
you know, just like there's
no money. Like, you know,
he was in his sixties and people were
coming to them with these roles that,
you know,
weren't that interesting.
Or if they were interesting
was an independent movies,
there's no money involved.
And then he started doing standup
again. Remember? He did a special, yeah.
But standups,
one of those things you can't fucking
take a decade off and then give
back in the saddle. I think a week on
week off. Exactly. Isn't weird like that.
Absolutely. It's, it's, you know, it's,
it's a muscle stand up had said
atrophies very quickly and not out there
chopping away at it.
Yeah. I remember I got knee surgery
once. I had to take a few weeks off,
took like three weeks off.
I had my ACL reconstructed and I went
back on stairs and I was nervous as fuck.
I was like,
I know, isn't it weird?
That's how you know,
it's still a scary thing
to do for a living because
when you've been doing it 26
27 years and you're still a little
nervous. Yeah. That's when, you know,
cause this is still fucking kind of a
creepy thing is bring it takes balls.
You know what I mean?
Especially for me when it gets nerve
wracking is like right now because I just
released a special,
so I have to
station wagon about, put it
away. It's all gone. I know.
That's where you're at now too.
Right. Absolutely terrifying.
And I don't live in the city. I live
40 miles north of New York City now.
I got to drive in and it's a fucking,
it's 80 miles a night.
It's a real pain in the bottom. It's 11
degrees out. I'm laying my couch trucking,
eaten a slice of pizza,
and I got 1110 at the seller
and you've got to do three sets.
I don't buy those days. Well, you
know what I'd do? I'd go to the stand,
this other club and I do a full half hour.
They let me do a full house
so I can get something done.
And it really came in handy when I, when
I did this, another senseless killing.
It nicked yp.com stuff
for me. Yeah, that's real.
Erica stands one of the best
ending a billionaire clubs
out there. Yeah. It's an,
it's an intimate little,
it's a small spot.
Some nights it's got a really Fifi
field too. It's almost like Fifi. Yeah.
You don't want a little anything, a
little off color. And they're like, Ooh,
it gets so angry. He'll say some hateful
mean shit. I got fucking liberals.
Yeah, well that's true cause nights
where I'm absolutely wrong, but there's,
but you got to admit, even
Chris Rock said, Oh really?
He did a whole article how
it's not even fun anymore.
The kids are so PC and they get fucking
Venta and this is coming from a black
guy. You think he's going to
get in trouble saying anything.
Give me a fucking break.
Colleges,
he was talking about colleges to
stop doing those as long time ago.
My second year in the business I stopped,
don't call
Barry Katz sent me to Clark University,
which is in Wister.
It's even liberal for
Massachusetts school. Yeah,
and I did some stuff about Middle East
and ours is something, some kid goes,
what are you going to do a Bush and next
of that I said I just winged it much,
a hateful a boy and shit and it's the
only time I got off early in my life.
They fucking hated me. That
was like, how does it go?
There was like 1991 three
years after I started. I,
I've done a handful sense now
when you do them, they request,
I'll do them if they request me
and they know what, what's common.
I did one upstate
cup a couple of years ago,
upstate New York and it was surprisingly
they were open to anything I was saying.
Yeah. Cause he laid on ponies. You need
to go to a shitty school. That's her.
That's actually a good point. Yeah. If
you go to Harvard you're fucked. Oh fuck.
I did MIT when we first started,
but I had TV clean shit and they liked it.
It was really Evie clean. Yeah. Anyway,
I wasn't saying anything
and they liked it.
Well Nick and I came up in the time just
after Steven Wright had made it does
this big scramble is like that movie
standup, one standup stood out.
France all need a movie,
great fucking movie.
It's all about the Boston scene and
it's sort of really accentuates what
happened in those days because Steven
Wright was such a rare talent that he came
along and there was all these guys that
had been around before him that were
just doing it. To be funny. And it was
pure, like there was no going anywhere.
Like those guys were national
level headliners like Sweeney,
uh, Nox, Gavin, you know,
Kenny, Rodney Clark, all those guys,
Mike Donovan, national level headlines,
but they never went anywhere.
They all stayed in town because all they
were trying to do is make each other
laugh and like get the respect of
each other and kill the crowds.
But this fucking guy,
Steven Wright came along and his act was
so unique and so weird that he got on
television and also needs
is national huge superstar.
And so everybody kind of became
like squeaky clean like TV guy.
And that's,
we came in right when that was happening.
You were like a little
bit ahead of me and right,
right when we came in we were like,
why is everybody so how come we can't be,
you can't swear
what's, well I don't remember
Sweeney of a doing that.
And he thinks when he needed it. No, no,
he just stayed himself. He didn't budge.
I'm not doing it. But he
was already a huge star in,
in Boston, Boston, you know. But, but
that's a good point Steven. Right,
because the guy from the tonight show,
it has happened to be in Boston.
This is all part of that movie.
When standup stood out, the,
the guy that books a comedian for the
tonight show back in the 70s when Carson
was hosting,
it was the thing to do.
He was in town looking at schools for
his daughter and he saw the Ding Ho ad in
the paper and he went to the Ding Hall.
That was where the first comedy club,
that Chinese restaurant remember.
And so he said, I want to go.
I'm coming there tomorrow night.
So they made up a lineup and almost every
comic in Boston went and Steven Wright
was in that, in the mix. And he's
the only one that didn't do that.
Well when the show was over,
all the comics went up to meet the guy.
They were trying to shake
hands with him and, and,
and Steven Wright just left cause he
did so bad. That's what he says in the,
in the movie,
and he's the one who got the call.
Wow. Well, he was so unique.
Yes. That fucking act.
When I used to work at
a fire hydrant factory,
couldn't park anywhere near the police.
Isn't that pot material? But
when I hear stuff, I'm like,
that has to be,
we'd material used the best week.
Do you know? He lived next to
me when I moved, when was in la?
I moved a couple times.
I moved to Sierra Benita here in West
Hollywood and I'm moving to this shitty
building. And the guy goes, and this
is before anybody who knew Mitch was,
or he goes, you're a comedian.
How? I go, yeah. He goes, well,
this is a standup comedian. He lives
right next to you. And I go, well,
what's his name? He goes, I
don't know, Mitch something,
no, whatever. And I'm like,
I know, I never fucking heard of
them. And then you know about,
I'd say a month and a half later,
two months later, I'm watching TV.
I was on the road somewhere and he and
my neighbors on the enlightenment and I
go, this guy's is funny as anybody
I've ever fucking heard in my life.
It's got Scott lives next to me.
And then he did a joke about me
cause I used to bang on as well.
He used to play guitar or his
wife or his girlfriend did.
They used to have the sing alongs
and shit. Not Bang on the wall.
Like shut the fuck up.
And I'm in shock. Rob. Yeah. And uh,
so Zoe from the Improv, so we might, yeah,
she was in New York one night. She goes,
she was there to help Mitch put his, let
him say, she goes, you know, he has a bit,
it says Depaulo on the Napkin
that says Depaulo on a Napkin.
And that's the bit of I'll evening
banging on the wall and he goes,
there's no door knob come around to some,
but something about the door opening
and a wall open it. And I love this guy.
I'm trying to watch a football game and
then fucking they're doing singalongs.
Oh, that's hilarious. And a, I
just felt so bad. We, I got them.
I remember leaving in my case, a Heineken
or something. Oh really? Oh that's cool.
That's funny man. But it
broke my heart. A Guy,
he was a guy that got a development
deal, like great standup, right?
Killer stand up.
But then they wanted to put him on TV
and put him in the movies and shit.
And it just wasn't his thing.
His thing was doing what he was doing.
But that's the weird thing
about Hollywood and stand up.
It's just like they take a stand
up, they go, man, that you,
well you need to do is you need a host,
a fucking talk show
host and they'll give a stand up,
up talk show or give a standup a sitcom
and give him some fucking canned lines
and reps. Silly. Right. But he, he did it
for a little while and then it was like,
fuck this took his development deal
money bought a cabin in big bear.
Is that what he did? I didn't know
that. He lives in fucking big bear man.
He lived way early. I think
she though they still own
it. Right? She still owns it.
Um, and yeah, he had a cool fucking cabin.
He would just go to the mountains and
hang out. You know, I was like, Ooh,
I liked that guy. I live in a world that
seems like comics. We like to do that.
I lived in the woods for a while and I
live in Colorado. I lived in Colorado.
Yeah. My dog had eaten by mountain
line. My wife got pregnant.
No, I could've killed a mountain
lion and we would have been fine.
I have set that little
fucker up. But uh, the, uh,
eight my dog man, but my wife getting
pregnant, we were at 8,500 feet above,
above boulder, like 3000
feet above boulder and it
was really thin air. And you,
if you're pregnant up there, that's going
to be tough morning sickness is brutal.
It was like she had the flu every day,
so we had to get out of it.
And she did not drive in snow. Well, which
one was it, Joe? It was all the above.
It was everything. It was, we were
isolated, man. We were in the woods and
one of our neighbors got it. It's his
car eaten by a bear. And when I say,
I mean they the fuck fuck the
mini coupe. Black bear. No bears.
When they smell leather seats, they don't
know that that's not food. So the bear,
the bear got in. I bet I could find
it. I Bet I could find pictures of it.
Fascinating. Uh, hold on
bear. I got cloth seats, car.
My car's fine,
Colorado because I saw the
pictures online. I was like,
you gotta be fucking kidding me or scare
the shit out of me and I'd rather get
eaten by a shark or whatever
the bear thing to me. Yeah.
I went Edison's the legends of the fall.
I can't sleep. I liked eating bears.
I like take good. Get them anymore coyote
problems. Joe With you're a chicken.
I got coyote. Yeah, I've got
24 I used to have 24 chickens.
Now I have 20 fucking does the acid
and raise chickens and fucking Kung Fu
expert. Fucking crazy
motherfucker. I like experiences.
Nikta [inaudible] I know you do.
Um, I'm just saying, so anyway,
this fucking bear in our neighborhood
broke into this car and just ate it.
I mean, fucking ate the car. Eight
to seats eight. The dashboard.
I'm trying to find the images.
I can't fucking find them online.
I should have bookmarked it.
It's the craziest fucking thing you've
ever seen because I would have think that
a bear would. What's that? Oh
No. That bed when I was in holy,
Jesus fell off of a trampoline
and Cheney shot and fell.
They tranquilized it and it fell out of
the tree. No. And Landon on trampoline.
So it just started bouncing. Yeah,
that's true. I saw it. Really?
Is there a video? It'll probably
get us pulled from youtube. Really?
Yeah. There's people that own those
videos. They get make money off the ads.
So if you play them on a podcast, they
put you in copyright. The Xing really?
And it's a pain in the tech
man is a real pain. Anyway,
this fucking bear just absolutely
completely mauled this guy's car.
And my wife was freaking out about that
too because the fact that these fucking
giant animals and they weren't even that
big. They were, they were black bears.
Yeah. That's, what is that
one that did it? What was it,
a salmon and Terry as this another,
uh,
it happens all the time because of
people and national parks leaving like
sandwiches and their cars and stuff
and that period blood hearts period.
Blood bears are so fucking powerful.
When we went bear hunting,
I was with my friend Cameron Hanes and
we were on the ground maybe 20 feet or 20
yards rather in front of these
fucking two bears that were fighting.
I wouldn't do,
it was the craziest shit ever.
It was like watching a UFC with bears.
It was a male bear trying to get to
the female and her cubs. The cubs,
when they see a male bear, they
run up trees. Male bears eat cubs.
It's one of the first things.
You don't want to be anywhere near
a female bear and her cubs. Exactly.
Exactly. Exactly. Yeah. Well we
couldn't move once we were there. You.
Last thing I want to do is run.
You don't even want to back up.
Not like if I lay down
and it's a big thing about
bears is about, it's about, um,
it's about, um, uh, body language.
If you back up your prey,
you're their dominance. You'll give
them the finger. You have to stand up.
If bears come near you, you have to
stand up and you have to move towards.
You don't play dead.
You have to get up and go like this.
Are you going to do that? Really? We
did. You have to. If you don't do it,
you get fucking eaten.
And I'm not bullshitting.
They ate a kid in Rutgers just I know
the Indian kid and then I made a joke
about a shitting in the woods. Well,
he does now. He Ate Indian. Oh,
how dare you. Spicy Curry. That kid
took pictures too. You saw the pictures?
Yup. Yup. People like to take selfies
with bears. That's my worst nightmare.
I'd rather a shock or a cramp there.
People have a lot of weird
ideas about what bears are.
They have these ideas that somehow the
bears like these cute little cuddly
forest creatures that are eating
berries grew up that way. Teddy bears,
we should not give kids a teddy
bear. The teddy bear. True.
Well especially like what would
you do for a Klondike Bar? Yeah,
fucking polar bears and Coca Cola bears.
This is a real fucking coca cola bear.
That's what they do. Those goddamn
polar bears. All they eat is meat,
deer or something like that.
Now how does he get the blood off his for?
He doesn't go swimming. We'd
go to the cleaners. Gab,
he swims or you just walked around with
blood all over his face like a fucking
g. He doesn't give a
shit. It wasn't carried.
It looks like he's a polar bear.
There's blood on my coat there had
goddamn terrifying you animals.
We played the video, didn't we have the
guy that was in that big plastic box?
The giant Plexiglass,
some guy from the BBC sets up this box.
That's huge.
Bulletproof steel reinforced box in
polar bear country and this giant fucking
polar bear comes over and
he's trying to get him.
He's trying to eat the box and
he's huge fucking mouth in this.
Guys inside this box, shit,
his pants shaking the box.
You realized how strong those
fucking things I, that's like I said,
I'd rather be in a shark cage. Have you
ever seen the video? I don't think so.
Playing that video. Just play him on
this. Can you play it on that Jamie?
She's fucking right. You
have to see it. Cause it's,
he's fucking God damn terrifying is
there's so many animals out there that are
just unbelievably powerful and terrifying.
And we have these ideas about them based
on like cartoons. Oh yeah, he and booboo.
You know like all the like really
scary ones. Like polar bears. Oh,
how about this pad? Vicious toe. They're
vicious. Yeah. Koala beavers and got,
got killed by a fucking beaver this year.
But that was an era of disease.
You have a fucking comic to the bone.
The bone.
All right, because at the bear,
no, that's, that's white guy. Oh.
Oh Hey skip ad. See
that button. Click that.
It goes, look at this, this
fucking guy in this thing.
And if Brian, what is the name of this
for folks who want to watch dumb? Fuck.
It's called starving polar bear.
BBC. We'll bring it up. Oh God.
So this is Jack Ass decides
he's going to sit in this,
this big glass and you know,
bulletproof glass and steel box and
this bear just goes right to them.
No fear. Enormous animal.
Probably fucking, you know,
1300 1400 pounds. Who the size
of this fucker? Yeah, that's a,
Oh God damn.
It freaks me out.
Look at the cute little face and then
he's going to bite your head off. No,
just holy Jesus. Well you don't even
know. Wait till he gets up there.
He's just smelling it right now.
He knows there's meat inside there.
So he starts getting really close
and then he starts trying to bite it.
Look at this. This is where it gets really
crazy. He starts pushing it. This guy,
he's tightening down the latches and
you make sure a good time to tighten the
meal. I want to know how they even
test it with the size of that.
Fuck you gotta be shitting me.
How did they even test this thing?
It's trying to get him, I mean, he's
trying to open that thing up and get him
this guy.
What are the only animals
that actually see us as food?
Yeah. I would want a gun. I
wonder if he's got a gun in there.
You have to have some kind of backup.
Right? Just in case. If it does happen,
I would hope someone who's filming that
from a distance has something like bear
spray or something.
He'd look at the site,
hope trying to hug him.
He's clawing at the fucking look at that.
Oh God. Jesus Christ. Yeah,
because they're not
like even grizzly bears.
They'll eat berries and grass and they'll
lead all sorts of plants, but not,
and then wash it down with human blood.
Polar bears don't have
anything around except meet.
All they're doing is just eating seals
and the occasional hiker. Yeah. They,
they creep me out more
than I think they should,
but meanwhile I look at this
asshole swimming with one.
The guy who's got his own pet look at
that. Oh yeah. That's fucking jackass.
And I went to school in Maine.
They had fences up along the campus to
keep the bears off the railing. Yeah,
but those are brought black bears,
right? They're still dangerous.
Apparently black bears are more likely
to kill people than brown bears.
Just Brown. You just being
racist. Ah, what am I saying?
Apparently black bears will eat people
more often than a brown bears will. Black,
brown bears are just bigger and stronger.
Brown bears will avoid you apparently
more than black bears. Well,
yeah,
but New Jersey especially has a real fuck.
I know they got to Reno.
It was just going to, I mean,
I live in Westchester. What's
the difference? And you,
why'd you move out to Westchester?
What made you want to live out there?
Honest to God, no tunnels and old bridges
on the way into the city. That is nice.
But the property taxes are through the
roof and it's, but I love it. I love it.
Oh yeah.
It's the worst in the country really.
One of the words were mentioned like
five different articles on the New York
Times,
but you were in like,
that's what part of Westchester I'm up
without telling anybody because people
will stalk you up by the,
uh, by like Chappaqua area.
Briar cliff.
I was listening to you on a res podcast.
He was talking about your neighbor.
Huntsman is falling back yard. Yeah.
Sometimes they'll look out the window
and he'll be like walking through our ag
and a deer blood shit. Love this guy.
Love this guy. Does he bring over meat?
He gave me a venison roast for
Christmas. Really? Yeah. I love this guy.
I'm not yet.
No,
a couple of days ago they were late
exchanging gifts but uh oh that's cool.
I love that shit. Oh yeah. I
mean, and we have the same thing.
I got a small dog and we have coyotes
at, you know, let the dog out at night.
You're going to go out and clap and
applaud to keep the willing. Yeah.
To let the coyotes no,
you there and shit.
Apparently they say
there's like a certain,
like things he could set up that make
us sound a certain sound that coyotes
don't like and you set them up and
they can keep a lot of the coyotes out.
But they're smart. Those little
fuckers, they, they figure shit out.
They recruited my dog.
That's how I'm really, yeah,
that's how he got away with
killing one of my chickens.
He became my dog's friend.
Like they go around my dog and you know,
they would like play I guess
like outside the fence.
And my dog would bark at them and wag his
tail when he sees them. Oh my God. Yeah.
And when, uh, he killed a
chicken and ran off with my dog,
killed a chicken to my dog,
had broken into the side of my yard
where the coyote was. Some of the left,
one of the gates open. We have two gates
and one of the gates you could Kinda,
he could shake it with his paw and he
could open it up and he figured it out.
And so he ran over there to hang out
with his pal and go on a fucking, uh,
an orgy of slaughter.
Was it you or whoever Burt or whatever
that said something about the, the,
the coyote limping that was trying
to trick, uh, oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
That was actually, I'm not even us. That
was a, the [inaudible] scholar. Butters.
Yeah.
We were all hanging out in the back of
the comedy store and they were telling us
that Pete was a PDC.
He,
I parked up in the hill
behind the comedy store,
which is a lot of comics do they
part way up in this huge hill,
cause there's like a street that they
can park on and then walk down the hill.
And he said he was getting out of his
car and there was a coyote limping.
That was, he was like, oh my
God, why is this coyote limping?
And he's just kind of nervous.
He's like,
I'm just going to let
this coyote walk by me.
And then suddenly this pack of
coyotes just started walking past him.
Like I said, they were doing the
exact same thing with the limping.
They set it up where they make it look
like they're hurt and they were like,
well, they'll limp. So it's her job.
She used to do videos to get girls. Yes.
He would pretend he was hurt
or kill his dude. They be,
can they have a cast on their
arm and they're on crutches?
I remembering the Ted Monday,
I didn't know he did.
That girl comes over to help him.
He's trying to put a couch
in the back of a van.
He's pretending he's got like a cast on
his hand. The girls kind of salt lamps.
That's like, that's like a,
that's prepay. I didn't know.
I thought that was a human thing.
I didn't know. I didn't know animals
were doing. They fake a limp. Yeah,
they fake a limp and they'll also
become friends with your dog and then my
neighbor,
he has like a beagle little beagle and
he says every time the coyotes come near
his house,
the beagles starts wagging its tail.
I think it's the coyote is his friend
and if they can get the dog outside and
they just maul it and kill it,
it did creepy.
Well he thought it was just they
smelled it and fucking attacked it. No,
they're smart man. They
developed tactics. Well you know,
they're similar in a lot of ways to
wolves and wolves have a lot of like crazy
tricks that they do to uh,
to get animals.
We'll set up ambushes like wolves will,
they'll funnel like elk and deer until
like a path. And then the weight,
they'll have other wolves waiting.
I don't how the fuck they work this out.
I don't know how they,
the internet
email,
what did they do that lets them figure
out that this is a good strategy and how
do they know like who's
going to be the chaser?
Who's going to be the guy that waits,
you know, how do they coordinate this?
But I guess when you're fucking starving
and the only way you get food is to
kill it with your face like you,
you work shit out and the streets.
Martin's why it is kind of street smart.
Think of a crazily fake limping.
I'd, I'd never heard that.
That's unbelievable. They
have a real problem. This one,
a retirement community,
there's been some insane amount,
like more than 30 over the last year,
uh,
coyote attacks because they
figured out in Arizona,
they figured out that old
people are fucking old.
You know the Kyries realize this guy's
not gonna stop me from genus dog.
And so they just run up and
snatch dogs right off the leash.
They'll literally wait for someone
to be walking their dog, the weight,
and they'll see the guy with
the dog and then just run,
run right out half the number of 10
or 11 you wouldn't walk your dog and I
fucking air.
Well,
especially if you live in fucking
Arizona where you can carry a gun gun,
do whatever you would walk.
Like Arizona is a open carry state.
You don't even have to have
a concealed carry permit.
You can do whatever the fuck you want
and you can keep a gun, your underwear,
you do whatever you want.
No helmet and gun on your mouth.
No helmet on the motorcycle and gun
coyotes loved the smell of absorbing Jr.
Just walk your dog by a motorcycle while
you're armed. Yeah, that's it. Just,
just slowly all over the neighborhood.
Just idle and just start unloading
shotgun shells on these fucking country.
While
I really wish we could get a motorcycle.
I wish we didn't live in la cause
it's so tempting to give me my money.
Are we riding together?
Like what do you got planned?
Going to get a side conference.
I get with those goggles on
because there's so many
people at the comedy store.
They're getting new motorcycles
lately and it's just so like,
and it's not that expensive. I thought
motorcycles where like the price of a car.
They're not that bad. No, it's not bad at
all. Dean Dean is always a ride in his,
I don't trust del Rey. Yeah.
That's a fucking dope motorcycle.
He got to that fat Harley Davidson. That
thing's amazing. Police car won yet.
He has a police motorcycle.
Police motorcycle. It's
cool. Oh yeah, they'll load.
It's kind of like sorta police colors.
Yeah.
With a side car. Side bags on
it that things may, I asked
him about it. I go, dude,
that thing's amazing. I go, do you have
close calls? He goes, all the time.
I got kids.
Well Louie,
I was living with Louis in New York
right after we moved to different places.
He got a bike and and sure enough man,
like after, after like three weeks,
he was doing like 60 down, you
know, by Columbus. So when it goes,
gets hit going through her fucking
intersection, you get t boned.
I mean, could have been killed,
login easily. He got hit hard flying,
got knocked out.
I almost got a bike.
I was going through the motorcycle
training thing and everything.
I was going with a couple friends of
mine and they wound up getting bikes.
But two people I know gotten some
pretty serious accidents. Uh,
a buddy of mine fell.
He was going through the canyons and
he fell and fucked his shoulder up.
And then another friend,
Frank Mir was the UFC,
one of the UFC champions.
You got hit by a fucking car and
got launched 60 feet in the air.
Some old man just ran a red light.
So looking to hit the gas and shattered
his femur. That's the thing. It's,
it's not you, it's the, he
almost lost his leg people,
the other people drive and they don't
trust. Exactly right. Exactly. I mean,
crashing your bike if you're
going fast can be fatal for sure.
But most accidents occur because you're
involved with another vehicle, you know,
unless you're driving like a psycho.
I mean,
but it's even tempting just to be like,
you know what,
I'll just drive around my house,
my neighborhood, you know, like,
I'll just go to the store instead
of doing nothing on the freeway,
I got an alley to go pick up a sandwich.
What's so fun? They are fun. I mean,
you think about it, you go to, I think
about this when I go, uh, to, uh, like,
like Disneyland with my kids and I'll get
any stupid fucking go karts. I'm like,
look, you know, I, I gotta
go cart. You know, I got it.
I got a sports car to drive it fast.
Like this is not that fun for me.
This is stupid.
But like a motorcycle like around your
neighborhood is just like going on a ride
at Disneyland. You know. If it's
fun to go on a ride at Disneyland,
it's way more fun to be riding around
your neighborhood on a motorcycle.
It'd be really fun.
Just convince yourself though it Joe.
But what's worse is those guys that I
think feel the same but they get those
like for motorcycle,
like where it's like a grown man,
like a white guy with one of those
four wheel motorcycles driving down the
street. Yeah, they should be. Yeah.
You should be off in the woods with
that thing and can be in the woods in
Tennessee with that thing.
Checking out your shine.
See if somebody broke into the
hut funding your trap line. Yeah.
Those things get people fucked up.
You know those for a lot of paralyze
people didn't Ozzy Osborne break his back
doing one of those problems, they fall
over on you. The problem with those,
it's different than a motorcycle.
Like if you slide in a motorcycle,
if you're falling,
you let the bike slide and you know
you get rug rash or road rash rather.
But on those things, a lot of times people
want them getting trapped under him.
They get crushed.
There's so goofy looking too though.
When you see a guy driving down the street
in that though they're real dangerous.
If you hit a bump, if like you hit a
bump with like your side and you know
it flips over on top of you,
you might get crushed and know you
might get your body cavity caved in.
Here's trail Ellen.
Yeah. What is he doing?
He doesn't have a helmet on Jesus Christ.
Let's see Chris.
That's football injuries,
Goddamn head injuries.
He's had two wheels in the
front and one in the back.
Those are apparently more
stable for some reason.
I don't understand why the hell is that.
That's like one of those things.
They have two wheels in the
front and one in the back.
I wonder if because it has all those
wheels, you don't need a helmet.
Is that or is that like in a
place where you need a helmet?
You don't need a helmet. A lot of fucking
states still don't have helmet laws,
you know?
Yeah. It's sunglasses and lie to play
like you have to have sunglasses on,
which is smart. That is the law of
bug or a pebble. I mean, you know,
pebble hit your windshield
50 miles an hour.
Dean used to always say the worst is
when you're behind somebody and somebody
flicked a cigarette out and
it'll go right into your coat.
Inner driving and it just like,
you don't know what to do.
He says that happens all the time.
It's cigarette fuck. Rarely. Yeah,
I see the little marble counter.
How many times can that happen?
I mean it happens all
the time on the road.
I see people throw cigarettes out there.
The car out here all the time.
When the lead man, he used to have a
joke about that. Remember, what was it?
She goes, I don't throw my
cigarettes out the car window.
Cause last time I did the
car behind me blew up. Well,
I always think that it was the
best job that though. Right?
Like you do somewhere inside your
engine it's going to go on the tank,
get in there and fucking lights.
It's all gasoline and shit.
Well not only that,
in La you have to be a real asshole to
do that cause it only rains once a year.
Here, everything's dry as fuck.
You know you can start fires.
They say all those roadside fires,
they all get started by people flicking
flicking a bunch out the window.
That's pretty sweet.
That is pretty,
that looks awesome.
Three wheeler duck thing.
It looks like a car tire and it looks
like you could front could be the back in
the back.
Could be that you could go either way on.
Do you know how many you can lay
down this way? It's a bisexual cycle.
It goes both ways.
It's like corvette size tires.
Look why those fucking tires are,
that seems like that would be
no, not that stable. Yeah.
I mean I, yes, I mean,
isn't the idea that you kind of like lean,
where do you drive that people
drive that shit all through La.
Like I see it all the time. Yeah.
Not this exact one. Is that legal?
Yeah. Yeah. I don't know. I mean, how
was it? Motorcycle legal. It's weird.
Like motorcycles illegal, but you have
to, you get a ticket if you have a seat.
No seat belt on.
Like I'm inside a metal box guys.
He's like sitting on
that thing just sitting,
sitting and holding on with his hands.
You know you could ride a motorcycle
by the way, if you have one hand.
How about that?
How about you have one hand and a,
you're just sitting on it and I have
two hands inside a box and I can get a
ticket if I don't have a strap around me.
Another big thing in Burbank
is this legal golf carts.
People just drive shit around era in
Burbank all the time.
It was like two or three
people just driving down the
street and golf carts. Boy,
they living on life at a breakneck
pace. Huh? What the fuck? Really? Yeah,
and there's a lot that's become popular
I think because just the gas mileage,
you know? Well, they're all illegal. I
mean rather, right? They're all electric.
I don't, I don't know this.
Is that the future out of them
electric carts? Yeah. Well fuck the
spot at all. Give me my pickup truck.
These fucking electric
cars they're making now,
they're slowly starting to get
better gas mileage or distance.
So they under $100,000.
No,
they're probably the Tesla's the good
ones. I mean you get like a Prius,
but those are ugly. That's what I want
to get behind two broads in a golf cart.
I'm late for an audition.
No gears.
Just a s steady buzz and 35 miles
an hour when they're pushing it.
Yeah. They got a new Tesla that goes 400
miles. That's like the newest, latest,
greatest one. They have a, an upgrade to
their little roads. Dirk was 400 miles,
but that's still not that long,
man. 400 miles on a charge. No.
Some shit hits the fan.
Isn't that just the guy just
get divorced and now he owes,
he's paying the girl like $20 million or
something like Elon Musk don't prenups
work. Uh, what every be I hear
about a prenup and I'd never worked
can test them for sure.
And a lot of times when people can
test prenups or any kind of lawsuit,
people settle because you took costs like,
yeah.
Cause of the UFC right now has a Elon
Musk divorce makes it most eligible again.
Okay.
If she has got divorced he would who do
and she were received 16
million. Yeah, she deserves,
because she helped with that company.
She was stuck in that sweet 16
every dog tick Joe. That's sexy.
That's misogynist.
You're going to get to know I was raised
in the 60s I didn't know any better.
I don't know any better.
When I grew up,
my formative years all occurred before
the Internet and social justice.
I didn't know
I was raised on James Cagney movies.
I don't know any better and I wish I could
think about those fucking electric cars
is you've got to get those goddamned
batteries from somewhere and all that,
all that shit from those batteries.
A lot of it comes from like where
it called conflict minerals.
It's comes from Africa,
comes from like the,
I'm fucking slaves pulling it
out of the ground. Like that's,
that's the big dirty secret
cell phones. Yeah. Lithium,
lithium ion batteries. A lot of that
shit comes from either Africa or a big,
a big supply they found recently in
Afghanistan. Like they're going to,
they're going to be
sending people to mind.
I'm sure a lot of chemicals over there.
Yeah. They, a lot of shit in the ground.
Minerals, lots of minerals, a
lot of natural gas. No roads,
no toilet.
Yeah.
And you know what they say also in
places where electricity is made by coal,
it actually is worse for the environment
to get your electricity to power a car
and then use it with a cold
fat Pi fired, uh, electrical
plant than it is to just burn gas
because the gas they have now,
like if you have certain, what does
that, Jon Jones has a gas, but no,
what he tests positive
for cocaine enters rehab.
No Way. That just happened. No,
John John's test positive
for cocaine enters rehab.
Oh my goodness dude. Now
wait a minute. Hold on.
When you do, cause it's going to ask
you that. That was the next question.
I don't think that stays in your
system very long. 30 days, 20 days,
something like that. It's
very short. Is it that long?
I thought it was like 30 hours
or something crazy like that.
Maybe I'm thinking 30 hours,
but
that's fucked. Let me call
shortly after we fight like that.
I wonder if he loses his title.
Quote from Dana.
I am proud of John Jones from making
the decision to enter a drug retreatment
facility.
He stated,
I'm confident that he'll emerged
from this program like the champion.
He truly is. Okay. That's a good thing to
say. I like to talk to him on the phone,
find out what he really thinks.
We're going to have an interesting
conversation that I can't talk to people
about it. That's exactly
right. I mean that's great.
Maybe celebrated the big victory
now I'm hoping. No, no way.
No Way. Cause they test them after
the fight. Like right after the fight.
They test him before the
fight or right after,
right after December drug test it says,
oh they didn't put the rest of my coat.
So yeah, I wonder what happens
is they tell us is going to be,
you know what? Come on. I don't
know about that because he won.
I mean it's probably a a non decision
like it's probably like a somehow,
I don't know. Vacate the belt man.
Yeah, they that cocaine you can't be,
here's how you fix it.
Here's how you fix this.
So you have a rematch match math
with they both coked up. Yeah.
It's a pretty common that he was doing
blown. He's still one. How about that?
How about Scott? He's, oh,
he's the most bad ass ever test
positive for cocaine metabolites.
It's brother with the patriot.
Best Pass rusher. They have,
it's a mayor and a couple
of tough mothers. Family
develop some stud athletes.
Did they ever, this is a,
this is really strange man,
that just happened.
This is cold being with the
Rogan when the news breaks.
You're great at that yet I'm not kissing
your ass. Be Really, oh thanks man.
I was watching like a year ago and it
was some guy getting the shit kicked out
of him and you go, um, yeah, but
the guys getting a little cocky,
I don't know who was winning the fight.
He goes,
he's getting a little too cocky and you
didn't even 10 seconds after that he get
the guy get knocked out.
You're the albums. Yeah. Wow.
This is crazy. This is really crazy. Um,
Nevada state commission falls the world
antidoping agency code and um hmm.
This, he tested positive for Benzos. Xylem
going nine. The main metabolite
and cocaine. That's the soul.
So by saying that that's
a metabolite and cocaine,
it means what you're talking about,
like really trace shit,
really trace shit and he's
already gotten busted in a Dui.
What do you mean really trace Josh's
small, very, very small amount
mounds.
Well,
get this
big ups with Jon Jones Body.
Oh Shit,
it's begun.
Starts Wow.
Trace amounts of cocaine.
I mean he could have just lik
day CD, CD or something. Yeah.
You could have had money.
Some monies.
Yeah. You got to have some,
they sit in the window sill,
like an x amount of a percentage of
like a hundred dollar bills have money.
Yes. When I worked at a
record store, we would get,
people would come in to sell their cds
and I just remember I would pick out once
and it was just white dust over and
I'm like, all right, we'll buy this one
and he would
scrape them together and we didn't know
what we're doing. We were just like, dude,
it has to be okay. What other white
shit would be on a CD and Hilkiah.
Right.
Wow. Yeah. Maybe they would get like
people that are like blondie fan.
They want it to die. It was just sell
them. She showing tits in her video.
Well, I am proud of that Mr. Jones
is addressing the issue. Oh, okay.
Friends bow.
Yeah.
Well he got tested December 4th okay.
That's a almost a month before
with the support of my family.
I've entered into drug treatment facility.
I want to apologize to my fiance,
my children as well,
my mother,
father and my brothers
making a mistake that I made.
I also want to apologize
to Yossi my coaches.
My sponsor's equally pointing my fans.
I am taking this treatment
program very seriously.
Therefore at this time my family
and I would appreciate privacy. Hmm.
And Bet you what? Well you know what man?
The dude is having a good fucking time.
That's what's going on. He's the
baddest motherfucker on the planet.
He's partying up a storm. Like someone
said something to me like, you know,
all those crazy behavior and all this
wild shit that he's doing. And I was like,
listen, you got to be a wild
motherfucker to be to do that.
Your baddest dude on the planet,
you really do.
And John Jones essentially when it comes
to MMA is the baddest motherfucker on
the planet.
I mean,
he just beat Daniel Cormier who was a
Strikeforce Grand Prix champion who trains
on a regular basis, holds his own with
the heavyweight champion Cain Velasquez.
He said,
you know,
in a heartbeat he would fight
the heavyweight champion
and he might be able to
beat a man who the fuck knows.
I mean,
he might be a better fighter if he wasn't
losing weight to get down to two oh
five and doing coke
202 to four days. It's why does it last
in the system? Yeah. Okay. So that means,
so if we look at his two,
we look at John Jones Twitter on December
1st or December or November 29th we'll
see exactly where he's like, you know,
hanging out where he was on the boat.
It was, how could the cop over there
fucking this fucking very clever.
He's just Christ. Take it easy
there, right? Yeah. Thank you.
Quincy.
You and I just hope dated each other.
Might as well have said Sherlock Holmes.
Charlie
has a hardy party boys.
Oh my God. I was trying to think
of a Goddamn detective division.
Can imagine it. Really.
It's fucking sad, Joe. Okay,
let's go to John Jones Twitter
page December. Okay, that's fine.
John Jones cut to him with his
face in a pair of stripper did.
Yeah. Jones. All right.
What do you think? December.
How far back you gotta go?
So I'm so December, wait, the test
was December 4th is that what it said?
So I would say I would
go December 2nd or first.
Oh, we try now. Let's go deep. Let's
go deep into the honey hole. All right.
December 20th two two two,
two, two tweets a lot. Okay.
He just got back from Brazil,
came over.
Cause now it says by Brazil sky
just figured the whole thing.
Oh, the Brian. Yup. Holy
Shit. That's how it happened.
Yeah. And, and you know what,
because it's trace amounts,
I will bet you that it was probably
something that's common that he maybe he
went to a restaurant and they had like
a coca leaf or there was some kind of
weird like thing, well, I'm going
to throw another theory that,
how about when a call me, his people was
over there and sprinkled in here, right?
Oh well we're Vember 30th
that's real thinking.
So he got tested on November
4th December four date,
December 4th rather. So he has four days
for it to get. Yeah, about four days.
I'm going to start doing that shit
again. Yeah, I didn't know that either.
It looks like is the most
likely culprit. Absolutely. Boy,
you guys put that together really quick.
The time partying up a storm. Yeah.
Here's the actual quote he says by Brazil.
Thank you so much for the great time.
Now back to the bootcamp
and that was November 30th
hmm. Yup. And there's a trail of
blood going up. The plain stuff.
What it is, the little
sprinkles on his Reebok's. Wow.
Why laces bloody what?
Wow. They get in a fight
with him when he's coked up.
How about the fact that he
was partying and doing blown?
He's still beat the best guy
on the planet per sale, man.
You're hanging out with that kind of,
but you're doing cocaine off of it.
You know, that's some hot chicks
out there having a good time.
You gotta be a wild motherfucker man show.
That's why I don't frequent those places
anymore. Yeah. Brazil or places. Sure.
He never been in Brazil. No
beautiful place, man. But the, the,
the contrast between poverty
and wealth is very shocking.
They're like right next to you, right?
Well, not only that, they're, you know,
all the Hollywood hills,
all the rich people live in the hills
and there were regular folks live there.
It's
the opposite in,
in Brazil.
All the poor people in the hills
with his amazing view of the ocean.
And then all the Rashid had
lived down on the bottom. Yeah.
So like they would have problems.
They've cleaned up a lot of it,
but they'd have problems in the,
people would leave the favelas and rob
people and then go back to the five Ellis.
You know the favelas,
like there's some like extreme
poverty and they were really mad.
They had the most like the worst homeless
population on the planet a few years
ago. Yeah, it can get bad and some spots,
but it's also like they're really
nice people. Like Brazil is fun, man.
I really love used to go there.
The food is fantastic.
They have those two Haas Korea's,
you know where they have the Brazilian
barbecue? It's like they cut the,
yeah, they have it here. You know,
you ever go on the phone with me and
Patrice late. Great. Patrice O'neil.
We used to go.
When you're doing short,
he's watching shorties and he
brought me to that place. I go, dude,
and this is when he know he had like
diet. I'm like, what are you doing man?
The guy's coming on this.
Yeah. He didn't give a fuck.
He just ate is eight and fucked
up his body. But in Brazil,
they got real mad because they spent
so much money on the fucking World Cup,
millions and millions and millions of
dollars to make these fucking stadiums and
bringing all these people in with all the
poverty. Right? I'm like, what the fuck?
Where are you guys getting this money? You
assholes. You could have been, you know,
putting these kids through school and
giving people food and it's a mess.
It's a mess. But illegal and,
uh, Brazil office, this isn't it.
Not banning competition in Brazil. He sang
it in UFC. It's not bad. Oh, it isn't.
Okay. The metabolites are not banned.
That's what it is. The metabolite.
It's not illegal. It's like if you have
a marijuana metabolites in your system,
like now it's legal. Like there's
a certain amount of metabolites.
You're allowed to have it. You, he,
they changed it by like a large number.
And it used to be,
it was like you could have like a trace
amount of marijuana in your system and
they could, uh, take your money away
and find you and take your victory away.
Like that's happened before, like with
Nick Diaz that happened, but now, um,
now you,
you could have quite a bit more.
As long as you're not high when you're
fighting, that's what they want now.
They think,
think you should be allowed to smoke
pot to relax after training and all that
shit. But marijuana stays in your system
because it's fat soluble way longer,
like seven weeks. Whereas, um, with coke
it's like, oh, a couple of fucking days.
I can tell you my marijuana story when
I came home from a dance club one night
right after I just, before I started
doing comedy, he was living in Malden,
Granada highlands up on the hill
there. Those are nice about it. Yeah.
I come from the palace
by pilots and Sagas. Yes.
We lived like a half a mile from it.
Okay. I come home, my buddies all,
when I come home,
shit faced,
there's a thing get tomato sauce and it's
like one in the morning, I'm starving.
I make spaghetti, I eat enough
for like five people. Okay.
I wake up like an hour later and my
ears are ringing in the rooms going like
this.
I started puking violently.
I hit my buddies, come in,
I'm in the bathroom, I hear
them going to the kitchen,
they go, he ate all the fuck
and they made Rasta Pasta
and they ate this much of it.
They said they ate like, you know,
a tiny amount.
They were fucked up all night.
And this is a guy who I only get high
at that point a couple times in my life
and that now my roommate's talking to
me. Right. He's right where you at?
He's like five feet away, but it sounds
like he's yelling from a mile away.
I was tripping on the fucking,
they were going to take me.
They didn't know if they should take
me to the hospital. I'm fucking puking.
I'm swearing at them and, and, and
honest to God, it was a week later,
I remember watching the Superbowl
and still being fucked up. I don't,
cause it's so much like you just said
when you went, when you ingest it orally,
it's way stronger and, and, and it little
resent my system. I don't know how long.
I mean, you know, you can look it up, but
I, and this is from somebody who didn't,
I didn't smoke a lot of weed.
That's crazy. A week later. Oh,
at least a week weekly.
No,
at least I'm probably being conservative
with that because it stays in,
if you saw how much I ate, you know,
if you saw how much tomato sauce,
such a grease ball and,
and uh, and they were like,
they were fucked up all my was like
this much. And they were like, oh no,
you're making up the fingers. Like a
hockey puck. Yeah. Forget I'm not on TV,
but yeah, about half the size of a hockey.
But it, and I was sitting there like,
you know, and my ears were ringing
and they would, like I said,
my roommate's like that close to me and
it sounded like he was yelling down the
hallway. I was tripping on the
fucking THC or whatever it is.
Yeah, it's a 11 hydroxy metabolite
is what happens when you,
the THC passes through the liver and which
they think was most of the way people
used to eat.
Well they used to take hash and eat
it back in the day and that's like
responsible for like a lot of the
psychedelic writing and then the,
the rig Veda and all the Hindu scriptures.
A lot of that was written while they were
on eating marijuana. Eating catalyst.
Yeah. It's like it's very
psychedelic when you eat a lot of it,
you trip your fucking balls off.
It's not like smoking pot.
You could smoke a lot of pot. You just
get really high. But when you eat it,
oh it does really crazy things.
I was a fucking match.
I didn't feel right forever.
When you closed your eyes,
you see nutty shit like hallucinate.
I don't remember that.
I do remember the voices though.
Well No.
Somebody talking to me being that close
and it sounded like they were yelling
down the hallway.
It was freaking me out.
I'm not a drunk guy in a
little blow like anybody else.
Your whole system has been so fucked up.
That's so much like I get scared here
when people talk about stuff like that.
Like I start getting nervous.
My hands are sweaty right now.
That's what I'm saying. What's the stuff
you do? I want to hear more about this.
Dimethyltryptamine the
thing about DMT is it, it,
it leaves your body really quick.
Like 15 minutes later it's gone.
But how long, how long are you on
that? Uh, will hi will you will your,
it's your sober in 15 minutes. Rarely.
Yeah. I might try the cit tonight.
It breaks your brain though. No, it does.
It does. What? He doesn't ever done it
and his brain is broken. So don't know.
Joe Seems pretty fine.
Expanded his horizons and
trust me your, you'll be fine.
I heard you talking about it.
One of those specials you would taking
questions and answers after and you would
just explain the shit.
I was in my car listening on the radio.
I was coming home from a
Gig and I go, Holy Shit, I
almost want to try this stuff.
Well, it's a good thing to
try and that it's over quick.
I took Tony Hinchcliffe, we did it
allegedly in Austin, Texas die. No,
no, he's alive. He's
doing well. But it's um,
it's like I can't explain
it and you can't explain it.
You just did great that
night when I was listening.
How it changes your perception of
everything. It definitely does that.
It definitely changes your perception
of everything. How about your marriage?
Did it,
I don't think it had any effect on that.
Does honestly is it shows you
that there's more that like,
supposedly there's like
multiple dimensions that exist
simultaneously all around
us. We only exist in this dimension.
This is like what physicists believe.
You know,
there's like 11 different dimensions and
it's probably that we just don't have
the sensory dep.
We don't have the sensory perception
abilities to perceive these things.
Like if you took a,
an aunt and you know,
you fucking held a book
over the aunt's head,
do you think they know that
there's letters over there,
they don't understand what
the fuck you're doing.
Like they don't need to
be able to perceive that.
We have developed and evolved with,
uh,
our abilities are perceiving
what's in front of us all the time,
whether it's hunting and
gathering or recognizing enemies.
Like that's where all of our
senses come from. Our hearing,
our feeling or touch to have sex, make
more people to know when you're hungry,
all those different things.
But it's very likely that there's a lot
of shit around us all the time that we
just can't take in.
And this neuro chemical that your brain
produces when you take it in large
doses,
it allows you a very brief but incredibly
potent window into what's likely there
all the time.
But what do you see? What do you
seeing visually is the change that,
to describe it to you? Oh yeah, you're,
the world dissolves, you know, you,
you live in a word.
Some of that
can of jesters and bike lights that are
indescribable geometric patterns that
are just infinite fractal. They go on
forever and it's the most potent thing
could ever explain.
I would never show it to you and
it like an Alex Gray painting.
This is like a little clarity. Yeah. Well,
this guy does all of his shit while he's
a paint doesn't mean doubt. Jon Jones,
a prom picture. It's snowball king is
when it says on his, uh Oh no it doesn't.
That's supposedly real. Well he lived
in New York, man had a snow ball battle.
That's true. Be Rude Brian. Seriously,
this is the kind of shit that you say.
Literally she should see shit like that.
I'll go a rug store. That's how fucked
gray. Oh my. He paints that when he's,
when he's tripping on that shit.
I mean he's a what you would call a
visionary artist and he is a very well
versed in tryptamine experiences, but
he's the best at like capturing those uh,
those images. And you saw stuff
like that. Exactly like that.
Like almost exactly like
you see shit like that.
But it's like moving and turning into
itself and unbelievable. Like, I mean,
but humbling.
Like you get out of it and you'd just
have a different view of the world.
Like your view of the world
just completely alters forever.
You've done mushrooms before? I
write and I haven't either. No,
you don't throw up on mushrooms.
Some people get it wrong.
Mixing it with garlic and tomato sauce.
A little fussy.
Yeah, it's like a, ain't not, no,
it's not shithead Bella right now yet.
Dope ass.
You've only done, you've done
the accidental eating of the pot.
A little bit of smoking and you know
everybody in the 80s I never did it, man.
I've avoided it. Avoided it. Really
never know what you're missing, Joe.
I had a buddy. You feel good and you get
really angry for the next three days.
Horrible. Not Interested. I
had a buddy who's a cousin,
was a dealer and I watched his, his life
erode and a, this is when I was like,
I guess I was like 1516 I watched this
guy, he was a few years older than us.
He had graduated from high school and
just fell apart and it just got real
skinny as hide. Haydn, his fucking,
they had an attic apartment.
They lived in his parent's attic or
something like that and they would just do
coke and watch TV. It was a
mess. She wasn't doing it right.
Well you have to be in a dance
club with a bunch of horse.
I think he was doing it because he had
a lot of it because he was selling it,
you know,
so he in it all the time and so I got
to see this guy just fucking erode,
you know? Yeah. You didn't miss nothing
that you feel good for like 15 minutes.
It's you fork. And then especially
with my type of personality,
like the crash,
right?
Oh I'm just depressed and not interested.
I never got the crash.
I never that I never got the bad part
of it cause that's cheery guy. No,
he's there all the time. He
lives in the crash. Exactly.
Chicks love it so much.
That's the best part.
Like I used to just carry
it around and pull it out.
If I saw a hot girl and immediately
you're in into her house,
you know like yeah,
they really did so crazy cause
they didn't get all sloppy.
Like when they get drunk and oh
remember our friends back in the day,
they would just like
put it on that account.
I have a friend who used to get it
just because he knew girls wanted it.
This is the best way to
get laid out like a trout.
He would only do it if they wanted
to do it. You're like, all right,
I don't do it with your shit.
Fucking hated it, you know.
But he would do it because it was
the best way to get laid. He's like,
if you don't have coke, and I got in late
and I was like, really? That's so crazy.
But when you got it got damn.
I would watch girls run after him just
run because they knew he had coke cause
it was like that term coke whore.
There's no, there's no coke studs.
You know there's no guys so good pint
bang in fat chicks because they got a
barrel of coke, their house. It's so true.
I bet you feminist would say that too.
It's not fair. We are whores when we
do it. You guys are dealers. Right?
But it is true,
right?
Like why does it is coke whore is a very
legitimate expression like or whatever
coke, promiscuous gow call it.
Let's stop. Call them cohorts.
Let's try, let's try to be kind here.
Coke, promiscuous female, you know,
but it's not like a coke man, you know.
Weird, right? That's true. That's true.
Well kills dudes. Dick's right?
It doesn't kill your Dick. No,
but I watch killed your deck. No, he
always says it kills his deck. I know.
I've never had a problem
with that ever Dick. Yeah.
I got Trussell Dick Trussell deck.
So how's that photo?
The guy on stage? Yeah.
You want to show that photo in the show?
Yeah. That, let's pull that photo up.
Jamie. We were at the
Mirage this weekend, uh,
doing stand up and a Duncan was onstage
and Killen I guess he was loving it so
much is dick got hard.
So he's got the pants on tight
jeans and he's uh, he's uh,
got a little woody and it's
so crazy because it's so big.
You noticed it.
Did you notice it that night when he was
onstage while I was on the side and I
didn't see it. But look at that. That's
does that, I don't know. It's very
calming. It's in the middle of that
photo. Got It. Perfect. Like
he's almost pointing it out.
It's like he's like amazing.
Someone sucking his dick and I looked
like a magician making it rise. Right.
Ah,
he has so much to Aaron Liba water.
Rodarius cauterize,
cauterize don't exist anymore. Does
anybody by quarter isn't one apparently.
Can you even buy corduroys those are like
Tan genes. But yeah, there was another,
there was a lot of fun times, man.
They were doing Ari and Dunkin kissed,
which was one of the best things
I've ever seen. Pulled it off for me.
My Instagram. Yeah. Yeah. They kissed, uh,
when they knew that the
camera's going to be on them,
they in Dunkin kissed like when they knew
the camera was going to be there while
the fights are going on because they were
sitting in the front row right behind,
I dunno.
And already had it in him.
They had done it until Brian sends me a
text message with a photo of the two of
them kissing while I'm doing
commentary. My phone buzzes. I check it,
and I see the fucking picture and I
turned to look at them and I held up the
picture. And thank God it was in between
fights because it was like, you know,
a big promo thing, you know,
fucking Conor Mcgregor,
they're doing all this shit and I'm
fucking crying, laughing. I mean,
tears are rolling down my eyes.
Watch this. Watch this. Watch.
Look to the left.
There's Ari Fleischer is ducking.
There's more time. That is, it's
so funny.
Dot Com forward slash the Joe Rogan
experience. Oh yeah, that's that.
W The guy next to you is I dust dusty.
He's laughing his ass. Oh, frosty.
Frosty. He's our sound guy.
Looked disgusted. And one of them was
laughing and they also did a funny
Illuminati. Oh yeah. It's not
Joe Rogan experience. It's instagram.com
forward slash Joe Rogan experience.
Just that. Yeah, but it's up
there. Fuck and Hilarious,
man. Those guys are so funny.
They're so silly. They have such, they
were on mushrooms too, by the way. Oh,
there are mushrooms all weekend.
They brought Ari brought allegedly
not true. I'm making this up.
If anybody's about about belt,
he brought to Shataki is about nine grams.
Saki and they were splitting them and
we were up til like five o'clock in the
morning. I couldn't do it. I can't.
I can't do mushrooms and then
watch people fight. Right.
I might pack up my shit and go home. I
might be like, I can't do this anymore.
I called up the UFC. Listen, I'm
call Kenny Florian. It's over.
I'm going to presale. Yeah, I'm going to
go to the jungle one with my inner soul.
I was in Montreal with
Arie and this summer at the
festival and him and Metzger.
I never saw so much. Wah. I
didn't, they weren't straight.
Perfectly. One minute. No.
All Week. He enjoys that weed.
Oh, Mike makes him happy.
Especially now that
he's doing really well.
Art is a happy motherfucker right now.
He said he's having so much fun.
His life is fantastic right now.
He's doing so well because our evening
nut fucking guy, he worked hard.
He worked hard for a long time,
but his comedy is so God damn good right
now and it's good because of hard work.
It's beautiful to see man.
I love watching the guy just really
like pull it all together and fucking,
I mean just through sheer,
I've known [inaudible] since
he was an open miker you know,
I became friends with them when he was
working at the door at the comedy store
and through sheer will and hard work.
He's a great comic now.
I fucking love that. I'd love
Shit. I love seeing that happen.
He's a fun dude. I was watching him
at the, at the festival, him and yeah,
him and Metzker.
Hopefully they would tweet and before
the festival about joking about working
with me and they had making giant Depa
will probably smoke enough a DePaul.
I'm like, well I didn't even really
know anything about these two guys.
I know they're funny cats, but I
didn't know how much weight. I'm like,
what are all these?
We'd jokes tweeting about weed
and me being like a straight guy,
oh the fuck they think they are.
And then I get up to the festival man.
And they were just the whole time.
Well you gotta be careful to in Montreal
because it's not legal. It's not right.
No. And you get busted with weed and then
you know, they deport you. You're fucked.
Ceville because right now my festival,
but you can't come back either.
I mean they'll, you know, if
you get caught with drugs,
like in some parts of Canada,
it's pretty much legal in Toronto and
it's pretty to legal in Vancouver.
I was gonna say makeover.
Yeah. BC though. I mean,
I was in a documentary called the union
that was based on the economy of a,
it would the,
the documenters based on how much
marijuana is involved in the economy of
British Columbia. And it's fucking
everything. It's, uh, if they,
if they pulled wheat out, if we didn't
exist, British Columbia would be fucked.
Like so much of the money that flows,
oh,
is that a reddish come involved
with marijuana? Huge part of it.
And this is a documentary
by my friend Adam Score,
GE who just did a recent one called the
culture high that Brian was into and um,
it's, he's just got these
great documentaries that
show like first of all the
hypocrisy involved and making weed
illegal. Why alcohol is legal,
whether you smoke weed or not,
it's fucking stupid and they
just highlight how stupid it is.
But it just shows you like
how so British Columbia,
it's pretty pretty close to legal but
Montreal not so much. I'm not sure.
I was a little more tricky and it's scary
to a lot of people in a lot of people
do is keep like old joints in there.
Ash Trays in their cars
and things like that.
You could get pulled over and get a Dui
and then not be allowed to go back into
Canada because they want
to let you have DUIs.
I saw my my car the other day and I had
to like a joint sitting my back seat and
I'm like,
dude,
I need to be not be the sloppy because
I would forget about the Dui aspect that
they can get you a Dui, but just being
stoned and driving, well not only that,
they're trying to crack down on that more
because look, the whole deal with Duis,
there's two things going on.
One,
they're trying to keep people from
driving and smashing into people.
When people die and put two,
they got to make collars.
They're trying to make arrests.
They get, they have fucking like,
they have a schedule that they had to
have to adhere to their quotas. Quotas,
which should be illegal because like
what the fuck would they do if everybody
decided we won't break any laws for a
year? No one breaks a law for a year.
What would they do with able to sway
off all the cops or would they treat him
like firemen where they just sit back and
wait for something to happen? You know,
nobody arrests. Nobody says, Hey,
it hasn't been a fire in six months.
How about we cut back on the
firemen? Fuck you. You know,
we know what it's like when there's a
fire. Keep the fucking firemen asshole.
But if there was no laws being broken
and the money wasn't coming in from the
cops to justify spending the money, you
know, on salaries and all that jazz,
I wonder what they would do.
We reach a point in our culture where
everyone's doing mushrooms all the time
and no one to the crimes,
no cops.
We hear what they're doing
now in New York City,
cops are saying that they're not going
to arrest anybody unless it's absolutely
necessary, which is like, Whoa,
what the fuck does that mean?
You were arresting people
when it wasn't necessary.
Isn't that a part of the God damn problem?
I mean there's sort of admitting
that everybody was right in that,
that when they arrested that Eric Gardner
guy like this is fucking arrested some
guy for selling and
selling loose cigarettes.
Like isn't there someone selling crack
somewhere? Is there someone beaten babies?
Yeah.
But the city Yag meant there is,
that's how tax hungry fucking de Blasio
and the leftists are that they go after
they, they suggest that they,
that the cops enforce those laws.
So because it, because the taxes,
they were losing so much money
with illegal cigarettes. Really? Yeah.
Cause they tax crazy in New York City.
How much money could lot eagle
cigarettes a lot. Yes. Yes.
So stupid. But that's how obsessed
yeah. With fucking tag, you know,
in this room to know that it's a left
wing thing that the left wing police or
the mayor is responsible for what we
would think of as a right wing act of
arresting someone. That's kind of fun.
Right? Yeah. Because like left wing,
like left leftist ideology would be that,
you know,
these are racist cops that are doing it,
but maybe it's the fucking,
it really is a tax issue. Right.
It's forcing these guys to do,
a lot of people say that
and now the cops hate them.
They're alternative back on
him on the flight deck. I just,
I know nothing about him. Well,
he's just a fucking knew all.
He went to fucking Cuba on his honeymoon.
That's all I need to know. He did.
And he helped the east as he's a
fucking mark. Just cock sucker. He went,
he went back in the day. Yeah. Really.
Holy Shit. He's, he's his
fire fucking left as they
come and what she's, whatever.
But, but hey, New York voted for him.
Whatever you get with your, you know,
you get what? Yeah. Do York is very
left though. She's really left. Yeah.
Well it's the two coasts. It's
here and you know, and, and I mean,
Chicago is liberal,
but not like that.
Not like putting New York is also
aggressive. It's a very strange place.
It's like there's aggressive, there's
progressive and aggressive. There's like,
you got your extreme left like
Williamsburg and you know, all these,
these Brooklyn people that are like,
you know, everything is like super left.
But then you also have like some,
I saw more racism when I lived in New
York than any other places I lived. Ever.
The word Negra just came flying out
of people's mouths like it would,
they had racial Tourette's.
Like I,
when I lived in Boston I didn't
hear nearly as much racism.
Where were you hearing that? New
York, a pool halls, uh, boxing gyms,
martial arts places, all those stupid
places I was hanging out in it.
Maybe it was the wrong hanging
out with the wrong people,
but I just heard a lot of racism.
I know a lot of road gigs.
I would hear racism
and a lot of road gigs.
It just seemed more accepted in
New York then. It wasn't Boston.
What do you think Boston's more
racist? No, I don't know. I just,
I don't hear the word anywhere.
Come out of white people ever.
This kid to say it around you. That's
what it is. Except the bedroom.
I bet him in the car.
I felt like when someone cuts you off,
it comes out of your own mouth.
But it seems like there's a weird thing
going on right now in New York where
they're trying to like fucking
fine, comfortable, happy
place, you know? Yeah. Well,
yeah, the mayor, whatever. Well, the
stock when it gets too political,
stop and search all that. Stop and Frisk,
Sinead, all that. An issue with he,
while he was campaigning to become mayor,
he painted the cops as bad guys and
then coming out and saying, well,
I have a son who was black
and I had to sit them down.
So you have to be careful around caught.
That's a fucking slap in the face to cops.
You're going to tell me a cop, a fuck.
Specially a white guy that goes into
the projects every night and rest his
fucking life to protect people from other
black people. He's racist. Mm. Come on.
Oh fucking, well not obviously this
bad cops. So you know, it's not good.
Every group has shitty people in it and
this guy painted them, uh, you know,
as the bad guys. And then you get Sharpton
involved. Who's a fucking scumbag?
I don't care what anybody says.
I mean,
you sit him next to the police
commissioner on, on, you know,
he's a meeting you have,
he's thin, he's a race panel.
So he makes his living and he said
was also a charlatan. I mean the,
the idea that that guy is expected at all.
You see him on CNN and the White House
80 times the last fucking it's for the
year.
I mean that the black community had
Martin Luther King who's like universally
praised and a great leader
and now they have al Sharpton.
Martin looked at Kingwood.
Well you can't have Jesse Jackson the
more you notice that Jesse Jackson's a
fucking pariah.
You know why?
Cause he got busted but scamming all
these fucking companies out of 10.
That's what she does. Exactly. It was
under and all. That's what he does.
He shakes down,
come Pepsi,
it goes to Pepsi and so you don't have
enough pig black people. We're gonna,
we're gonna pick it. And then they send
money to his action committees. Coalition.
Yeah. National Action Network and, but you
don't hear about Jesse Jackson anymore.
And then his son got busted. I remember
Jesse Jackson jail, right? Yeah.
He had mental problems. His
son like mentally ill. He
was on medication and stuff.
Yeah. It's just sad that the black
community doesn't have like a,
a real powerful,
respected civil rights leader today.
You know you're Al Sharpton will always
be defined by that. Tawana Brawley,
I mean you can just fucking quote pic.
You could quote mine a million fucking
things that he said that a ridiculous,
you know about how black
people can be racist.
It's only white people that can be
racist like stupid shit like that.
Like come on man. Everybody
can be racing on. Exactly.
Chinese people can be racist. Well
fucking Peruvians could be really what,
what are you talking about?
Like racism is not specific to like
one different nationality. It's,
it's the whole thing about being a cop
in my opinion is that being a cop is
almost a job that no one can do.
It's to have that kind of power and a gun
and then to see violence and crime and
people lying to you
every day at their worst.
You see people at their worst every day.
Yeah. And now and when you do all the,
all the statistics and how many times
cops interact it literally they do their
job right.
99.9% of the time.
I mean it of course is
bad ones here and there.
This whole 9% and they're interacting
with a thousand people a day. You know,
every 12 million a year,
you're getting a lot of
fucking bad interactions and
that was the ones that make
the paper.
Absolutely.
It's just the job that's like almost
impossible for a person. It's thankless.
That's why they should be treated
with respect, in my opinion. Yeah,
and it's not only just tankless, it's
also like the fucking stress, the PTSD.
Those guys must be under, they commit
suicide at an unbelievable rate.
Unbelievable rate. Petty's Oh
cups, Buckeye and soldiers.
Very similar in that way.
They both have very high rates of suicide
and they both see ridiculous amounts
of shit. It's just almost like, seems like
there should be a better way, but I
don't see about her way. I mean, I mean,
I don't see how you could live in a
world that doesn't have cops. I mean,
there's people that think
that, oh, we should live in,
I'm an anarchist. Hilarious.
To me, someone who's never
been in a way that's worked,
they must've never met an asshole, you
know? You never know. It's just, well,
they're in denial. Then it, yeah. Well
it's also like a cute thing to say.
It puts you in like a very progressive
camp and of of of you know,
a very high level thinkers,
elite leftist thinkers. You know,
I'm an anarchist and I believe
that we should all be free. Yeah,
there should be no laws and let the
market decide what the fuck out of it.
That all sounds good in theory,
but then when the rubber hits
the road it all falls apart.
That's how the Mongols came about.
If there was another,
if you can point to another system of
government that works better than that,
so I'll be glad to fucking open my ears.
How about a system of government that
works at all? It seems like we have,
when people get together as
a large amount of people,
you're just gonna always going to
have a certain amount of chaos,
certain amount of crime,
certain amount of people doing shit.
They shouldn't be doing a certain amount
of fucking victimization and even look
at the fucking shit that's going on right
now where we find out about bill Cosby,
a guy with money,
a guy with fame,
a guy with everyone loves. He
still doing creepy, shitty things.
Like you have to have a
certain amount of law.
You have to because even a guy like that
is doing fucked up shit. It's right.
Well it's about humanity with yeah.
And you know,
that's why we all have to do
mushrooms and DMT. Nick. Well Dude,
I listening to you that night. I
was ready to go find some, but uh,
all the stores are plus,
it's very difficult to find in a store.
You gotta go to the back. It's like
buying Cuban cigars. He got to know a guy.
Are we going to be able to
get Cuban cigars now? How's
that work? Yes. Supposedly.
When is that going to only
plus to this thing. I got a,
almost got in trouble taking some back.
I at the last minute,
I didn't take some back from Montreal
and then the fucking guy at the airport
literally asked me, you got any
cigars in there? I go, what?
Like I must have smelled like
a fucking cigar or something.
I don't know what happened. I go, what?
And he goes, did you bring back any Q?
I'm just asking you because
they are illegal. I go, no,
I definitely did not bring back anything.
And they opened up my bag and they
looked at, there was nothing in there,
but I was like, oh shit. Like this is
real. Like they actually bused people.
You go to jail for having a fucking cigar.
It's a taste. Any different for real.
I know one of those things,
right?
One of those fucking things like having
an alligator on your shirt, right?
You know like these are Cubans,
long law. I don't know man.
Kevin James and I used to smoke a lot
of cigars together and he didn't like
Cubans. He's like, they're too fucking
strong. They'll knock you on your ass.
Like there's certain Cuban, like
a punch. Like that's one of them.
And there's a few, a Hoyle de Monterrey
double corona and he's big fucking fat.
Stogies they'll knock your Darryl
and how the dirt, they make you high.
You know,
I used to
chew tobacco on college. Did you have
the, like the depth or the everything?
We had the depth that we had the Levi
Garrett leaves. That's the real shit.
That was the, those girls up there
chewing. No, I'm at the library one night.
I looked behind me. He's a
cute girl spitting into a cup,
but a, yeah, Levi Garrett.
The, the, the leaves and uh, that's
the real shit. Oh my God, it's bags.
Yes. I'd never done that
until I get up there. And uh,
but then now I stopped doing that.
And when I got out of college at my
buddy's house, he had some skull,
so I put a pinch of,
put a pinch in and I turned white.
It felt like I was sea sick. I got all
sweaty and shit. It's like when you young,
you can handle that, all this
stuff. Well, I just was like,
what the fuck I'm going
to Puke when I was a kid.
I was probably like 12 or 13 I was really
into Tom Sawyer and huckleberry Finn
and I wanted to try chewing tobacco
cause Tom Sawyer and huckleberry Finn,
those moms. So I kind of
like a, it was like a square,
like a little Brownie of chewing tobacco
and you break a piece off and put in
your mouth fucking 12 oh I don't
know how I got it. First of all,
why someone's selling me
chewing tobacco because I was,
I guess it was legal to get where I'm
like, I don't know how the fuck I got.
I don't know how I got it.
Like now that I'm thinking about it,
but I remember chewing it and
fucking puking my brains out.
The saliva build up in
my mouth. I was like, no.
Yeah I did that toe. I can taste it. I,
you know how like for a
long time I couldn't drink
Jack Daniels cause when sick
on it, yeah, we got
sick on it and know it.
I would smell it and I would
get sick just smelling it,
but that I could taste that chewing
tobacco right now if I think about it and
almost throw up cherry skull aspe
how about those little packets?
Like a tea bag? Yeah. That's pretty bad.
Well don't those give you like
massive mouth cancer though? Yeah.
They all do a video.
That guy or that guy who got his John
removed like you would go to like do these
public service announcements that uh,
schools where kids would be snuff.
He was like, no, fuck up some square jawed
captain America looking motherfucker.
And then all of a sudden he's
got like no champion. Like,
Oh half his tongue was removed.
Half my time when I'm with curing tobacco,
you're wiling to look like a baseball.
Probably not cool.
Everything's numb to him. Food tastes like
shit. Can't whistle, tastes like shit.
It falls out of his holding his side,
sloppy side of his face.
What's crazy is that they would advertise
not only candy cigarettes to kids,
but also big league chew, which is
like the chewing gum. That kind of,
it's the reason why I started
it. Yeah. He's like, Oh yeah,
like the baseball players. Remember big
league chew. This is the real stuff.
It's gum, right? Shaving Gum
shavings. That's pretty evil.
A lot of places they made those a
little candy cigarettes illegal though,
didn't it? Yeah. I don't think he could
buy me where Kenya wearing their leggings.
Weird. It's weird. He's
like the cigarette in
a fake gun.
If the fucking candy people were
involved in the tobacco industry,
then it would make sense like you know,
and then you would go ahead.
I'll be where if there's
a direct correlation.
That was the most fucked up
police brutality thing was
that 12 year old kid that
got shot with having a fake gun
and Cleveland, you know that one.
They shot him on in two
seconds of seeing him.
They got out of the car
and just started on,
don't drop the God didn't say anything.
Just started fucking crank, crank, crank,
crank. He didn't point it at him. I
don't know what the fuck happened.
I don't know. I wasn't there because
you have a split second. We hit silver.
We did a thing on the Chris rock show.
We did a sketch about that.
I was playing a cop every,
I mean every, every sketch.
But that was one of the things,
cause there was a shooting back then
and that was the sketch because somebody
recently get shot. The guy had a
banana, literally had a banana.
I was reading this in the paper and I
freaked out cause we did a sketch and
Chris rock where we were cops and
they will holding up pictures. What,
what's this? And it was a banana.
That was the whole geno and we'd go,
it's a gun picture of a bike.
It's a gun. It was really,
it was really funny.
But then I read it because he gave
some guy literally had like a banana or
wrapped in tin foil or something.
But you're a cop on the,
you have two seconds to make up your mind.
I mean what are you going to go?
Oh you get shot. That's
true. That is true.
And they're not driving by spraying of
12 year old. But then I did, it was,
he got released from another police
force for being like mental oval stable.
He's already trained and they hired
him and this other police force,
there's a bunch of issues.
My friend Justin was a real gun nut,
told me the whole story behind it.
Like he's a his right wing as he get
and he told me the whole story behind.
He's like, that guy was fucked up. Like
that guy should not have been a copy. So,
but they make,
you know,
there's a certain amount of money
involved in training one of those guys and
once that money's invested,
you'll,
they'll hire someone in another district
because of the fact they've already
been trained and you know,
you don't have to retrain anybody
and spend those resources. Yeah.
Too many second chances. When you were
working for, uh, for Chris Rock, I'm like,
did you work when you were developed?
Was he developing his specials?
We weren't. We would, we
weren't involved in that.
We were doing should in the
show he had his HBO show. Right.
We're coming up at such desired certain
guys though to work with a specialist.
Right. Like I know he um, Jenny helped to
them and well, well with like the Oscars,
he hired us, Richard, Jenny May and,
and punching up a couple of movies
and this is what it's watch came from.
He sent us up, ma'am. Actually
Tina Fey was there. Louie,
we met at a hotel for a day and
just like punched up a script.
Tina Fey writes a lot.
Does she doesn't do something before
she was famous right before she got real
famous. Should do stand up. That's
a good question. I don't know.
I don't think so. I don't think so.
Probably second city and all that.
But she was funny and was writing at
SNL at the time. So, but uh, yeah,
we went to some hotel for the data,
punch up a script and I remember
Tina Louie and whatever. But,
but like I bought about a month
later, we all get these Rolexes. Yeah.
And it's inscribed in the back.
It says for you help motherfucker is what
it says on the back. Well that's cool.
That's, that was the most fun I ever
had my life. We're going to dead show.
Oh my God. He was so laid
back and just, he'd come in,
it would be an 80 degree day. He go, fuck
it. Let's go to the Yankees game. Oh,
that's cool. And then, then a big momma's
house came out of what I, one of those,
remember big moment or Martin Lawrence.
Martin Lawrence in the
second one came out and he,
I think Chris [inaudible] himself and
then he made us all go see it because it
was so bad.
He made us all go to the movie. We all
sat down, we all had tickets. And then
20 minutes in this scene,
somebody,
him sitting on the toilet making
shit jokes and then Chris goes, okay,
let's call it the tall one.
Good to see.
That's all they wanted you to see.
We all walked out.
That's all he wanted
to see. I mean, because
it was that bad. Yeah. We were all
laughing our ass off. But how bad it was.
Yeah. I mean it was shit,
but it was what it was.
What I expected from a big momma's
house or whatever the fuck you know.
I mean I love Martin Lawrence, the
comedy store. I met him out here.
Dave Chappelle had a really fucking good
point about what is it about black men
in Hollywood?
They reach a certain amount of fame and
they make you dress up like a woman.
Like that is true.
It's fucking Eddie Murphy did it.
Jamie Foxx did it.
Marzi science conspiracy.
I'm sure he was.
But I mean it is kind of funny.
I mean how many white guys
dress up like a woman?
You got Robin Williams who did
a Fuckin Hoffman, Mrs Doubtfire,
Dustin Hoffman, tootsie. Um,
does it bosom buddies.
That's Tom Hanks.
But they weren't famous that they
became famous from doing that.
And that was sort of
a premise of the show.
They had a rent controlled place that
would only allow chicks or something like
that. Um, what was the one that
uh, you know who Patrick Swayze.
That's right. And again, that was
a fucking homeboy was in that too.
I'm Wesley Snipes. Well, how
about this? He was in there too,
too long food day to Julie Newmar.
What was the uh, Dallas Player's club?
Bababa Jerry Lego. Jared Leto. Yeah,
but he was playing a transgender,
he was playing like a gay brand.
No, I'm just listening chair front.
He's not playing a woman. An actual
woman like Mama's house like that.
He was playing a woman like,
it wasn't like he was wearing a woman's,
not the fucking conspiracy theory.
The white Hollywood guys make it
black guys present. But Ralph Harris,
remember Ralph Harris? He had a TV
show where he dressed up like a woman.
No Brown. Ralph Harris had like a TV show.
I remember Ralph Harris. Funny, funny.
He had a TV show where he dressed
up like a woman like on the show.
Robin Hair? No, Ralph. Ralph Harris.
Robin Harris was the funny guy.
I'm thinking of Robin. Robin Harris is
very far my, he was like great Robin.
Well he was fucking funny.
He was like the king of uh,
black la comedy for a long first time
I saw him. He caught it comes out,
I think it was like a def
comedy jam things up and heat,
but he had just a wife beater on with a
big gut hanging out and I was crying at
how funny
the material was just but just
working class. I mean, oh my God.
He didn't give a fuck. I don't know
if he ever really got really famous.
He was about to,
he was on the verge.
He had this one joke that
fucking killed me and he goes,
I don't ever mess with no pretty women.
Pretty women was too much work.
I don't like me an ugly girl. I tell
other girl, bitch, I'm going to the moon.
Oh, you be careful up there. I don't
want nothing bad to happen to you.
He didn't make his eyes big when you'd
say it. Oh, you be careful up there.
You have to say it, man. He was
funny. He was a funny dude. Bad.
He was a funny dude. This is a three hour
show. Yeah, it's over. It's over. We did.
You always do. All the time. Once you
start talking, look, how easy was it?
You just did it to no, I know
that's hard to do. No, I know.
I mean it's nice and have a studio
on cameras. I'm, I'm, I'm hunt.
I'm hunched over a card table in the
fucking red sox hat on my basement.
Where you all of a sudden, Holy Shit.
Did you see that you ran out of gas?
Three hours at the coffee.
I was like the fucking base porn tomorrow
I'll be up until for three days now.
Will you warm when you do your podcast,
do you do,
is it audio only or do
you have a camera on you?
I've only be done it like a little over
a year. How many episodes do you do it?
Once a week or once a week? I'm like 63
episodes in and I love it. I, I just,
cause I like radio. I
love radio. It's what it,
it's one of my favorite things is
almost as much as stand up. So,
but I don't have guests because I live
way up in the woods. Nobody's coming up.
So you just do it. You stop talking for an
hour. I treat it like a radio, you know,
I do new stuff. I treat it kind
of almost like a radio show.
Like bill bird does his stuff all
by himself too. Yeah. He rambles.
Rarely has a person on, yeah. Yeah.
He'll tell you read like a viewer email
or listener emails and stuff like that,
but I just,
I'll do stuff in the nose and despite
my personal life and just ramble.
It's a good, it's like a good
exercise for radio. Oh yeah. To meet,
keep it moving forward.
Try to keep them at the Tei and I like
to play with sound effects and shit.
I'm just like a kid. Like a
iPad or something. Yeah. Yeah.
I have run it through my iPad. Two bits
of glass. Try that for like one episode.
I was like, well you don't have
to look at you. She's like,
I feel like I'm at CBS studios.
Right. Well we're going to have a,
it'd be way more high tech
after today because we have
to fear factor cash son.
I will.
How about bad news radio wasn't exactly.
Yeah. That one of the syndication to
stop getting that bad being on here.
I'd love to just break into his
checking account for five minutes.
See what the fuck's going
on now. You're done. Good.
Thanks for having me on please.
My pleasure. Fun. What time?
Another senseless killing. You can play
clip or is it Nicholas? Yep. Dot Com.
We were literally out of time, but nick,
dip duck. We played one. That's hilarious.
But uh, this is it. Oh, you got it up
there. Another senseless killing. Uh,
seriously. Dude, I've known
you for 25 plus fucking years.
You've always been hilarious.
You're a
great comic and a great dude. Appreciate
it brother. Friends for a long time.
Happy to help you out anytime you want to.
Come on again.
You've got an open invitation.
I'll start this fucker up at
four o'clock in the morning.
This is the only reason I come out
here to la. Oh, that's awesome man.
Thank you folks. Go Nick, dip.com
go. Go buy this. Go purchase.
Get it respect nick. Depalo motherfucker.
Thanks. [inaudible] uh, what is your, ah,
your Twitter. Is it at
nick? Why Nick? dip.com not,
why not Nick Dipaolo get, you can go
to both. It's easy and it's spelled,
I try to make it simple. Oh, so if you go
to Nick Dipaolo like goes over to nick,
dip Daca, transfer it, then
that's fine. Dip is easier.
And Paulo spelled p a. O. L. O.
That's why I do nick dip. Yeah.
Aliens and grease balls. Yay
My friends. All right folks.
We'll be back tomorrow. So until they
ain't go fuck yourself. See you soon.
Much love big kiss nick
[inaudible] dot com go.